on twitter earlier today the word
gestapo was trending because people were
terrified after ron desantis proposed a
civilian military force rather scary
isn't it until you read the story and i
think even sarah silverman tweeted this
like please be you know truth matters
and everyone was surprised uh it would
be the 23rd civilian military force
they've existed in many many states for
a long time it's actually not all that
crazy what is kind of worrying is that
the tensions between the states and the
bite administration have gotten to the
point where ron desantis is like yo we
can't rely on the national guard or the
pentagon or biden to come to our aid in
the event of a hurricane or disaster or
something like that so we'll make a
civilian military force and of course
many of these individuals who are
complaining about gestapo didn't realize
that new york not only has lockdown's
mandates but they also have a civilian
military force but we'll break all that
down it's interesting we got some
interesting uh news coming from unheard
they interviewed a woman who actually
spent time in one of these internment
camps in australia and her story is
actually quite freaky saying they
offered her drugs because of her anxiety
they wouldn't let her go outside they
threatened her with fines if you took
one step off the porch of her building
that doesn't sound like hot babe sun
tanning that's what i was told by
colette and then we've got jessie
smallett's lawyer apparently claiming
the judge lunged at her and they want to
miss trial but
we're going to get in all these stories
and probably a whole lot more because
we're being joined by carrie lake who is
yeah this viral video where i guess you
resigned from mainstream media we'll
call it corporate press now you're
running for governor of arizona and
you've got a lot of opinions about a lot
of things and i think it'll we'll just
play into it it's a friday night we'll
chill and we'll go through all of that
so yeah you want to introduce yourself
real quick i'm the candidate for
governor and trump endorsed in arizona
and i spent 27 years covering arizona as
a journalist and the mainstream media
and and had a great career i was number
one at 20 for 22 years i worked for the
fox station and arizona is a unique
station a market because you reach 85
percent of the state so the name
recognition is really intense when you
work in a market like that and for 22
years we were number one
and at the height of my career making
good money working at a solid station i
just realized that the propaganda that
the corporate media is pushing is not
something that i can do
and it ceased being um just biased and
unethical and i think during covet it
moved into the realm of being immoral
and being a christian woman i just
thought i can't do this anymore i can't
read i was feeling sick reading the news
and i always felt that everything i put
out was truthful and it started to feel
where the kind of the walls were closing
in and i couldn't get the truth out as i
wanted to it was half truth well like i
walked away i can tell you the
confirmation bias of all of our viewers
is lighting up they're all really
excited oh good yeah yeah i'm kidding
i'm kidding but uh we'll get into all
that stuff for sure we got luke chillin
i i like to say satanic but that's
that's just me personally myself there's
a lot of exciting things happening in
florida and hell i mean i soon might
join the gator eating florida man state
guard especially if tim starts selling
more shorts that's why today i am
wearing my own official shirt which you
can support me if you get on
thebestpoliticoshirts.com the shirt
reads make florida america no it doesn't
no no no no
make america florida
that's something a florida man would do
uh florida man all the way and the best
political shirts.com thanks for having
me yo ian crossland here what's up
everybody happy to be here good to see
you carrie hi looking forward to talking
and learning a little bit tonight
i have a couple different things to say
tonight is our 420th episode
i really wanted to have joe grogan this
episode but i'm delighted that i'm so
sorry
i'll try to do my best but we're gonna
have super fun on this episode and i
just wanted to say i did see a comment
from somebody who said they grew up
watching you i think that's really fun
that's great i get that a lot yeah i'm
really excited it's our 420th episode
we're gonna need 69 000 likes so smash
that like button
before we get started guys head over to
timcast.com become a member help support
the work we're doing and let me just
tell you we had a new show it's called
pop culture crisis you can click it you
can check it out subscribe to the
youtube channel and a little rough
around the edges to get started but it's
okay that's how we do things this show
is basically talking about movies video
games books spider-man to give everybody
a chance to get away from the crazy
political space and we don't want
everyone to get wrapped up just in this
like dystopian nightmare we want some
positivity and you guys know spider-man
the new movie just broke end game and
last jedi pre-sale numbers i think it
might be the biggest movie of all time
i'm excited for it and it's not very
political it's not critical to the
health of the of the well actually it
might be
relaxing and watching entertainment
that's why we made the show and we were
able to do it because you guys support
us on this show and you support us on
timcast.com and you can also pick up our
poster and t-shirt by going to
timcast.com clicking store this is a
poster that is trolling the entire
nation
and continent of australia it says visit
howard springs and it's two people
chilling on the beach wearing masks with
razor wire as a man flees from a police
boat and it says visit howard springs
totally voluntary relocation camp
australia because we'll definitely talk
a bit more about that we've got that
story from unheard so you can support us
that way so again smash the like button
subscribe to the channel share the show
with your friends let's talk about
what's going on in florida we got this
story from cnn.com
desantis proposes a new civilian
military force in florida that he would
control i love how they frame it that
way as if it's like oh he would be in
charge i mean yeah he's the governor
right
but they also mention that if florida
goes ahead with his plan to re-establish
a civilian force which existed before it
would be the 23rd active state guard in
the country desantis's office said in a
press release joining california texas
and new york these guards are
little-known auxiliary forces so all of
a sudden all over twitter they're
claiming he's forming the gestapo and
the republicans republicans are nazis
and when i when i saw this tweet from
sarah silverman where she was like
please read the article the truth
matters i was like whoa
something said deborah messing came out
about the waukesha attack and said it
was a massacre call it what it is yeah
that was surprising wasn't it right and
but now sarah silverman being like the
truth matters i'm like wow
sometimes i think the holly weirdos are
waking up
waking up which is good they need to
you were you're telling us i guess what
uh if you were to become uh when you are
to become governor of arizona that's
right uh you're gonna do you were you
were gonna do the same thing yeah we've
talked about this already we had the
arizona rangers and they we we would
bring them back i mean right now they're
kind of a force that helps out volunteer
great men and women but we would bring
them back as a force we really need our
own border protection there because the
border patrol is not able to do their
job right now we have a border crisis
happening i'm sure you're aware of it i
know you're thousands of miles from the
arizona border
we have had many journalists and
witnesses on the show talking about the
crisis and i think florida is also
sending its police forces down to the
border to help texas enforce its border
laws as well and desantis had a very
interesting comment about this
announcement because he said one of the
benefits of this guard would that it
would be quote not encumbered by the
federal government right that's his
exact quote here that's why i'm like hey
maybe you know maybe i could give give
this a try he's going to start off with
200 volunteers he wants a budget of 3.5
million to start up this guard but when
we're at a situation where soon the
oklahoma national guard might soon
become the oklahoma state militia
because of federal policies this doesn't
seem like an absurd policy this seems
like a policy that is inevitable in my
opinion especially with how
hyper-politicized everything's becoming
uh from my perspective well even if you
take the politics out of it we have a
crisis at the border we have people
streaming across we have drugs coming
across
and coming into our communities and
they're not just staying in arizona it's
kind of like the slogan in in vegas what
happens in vegas doesn't stay in vague
is that what it is stays in vegas
hopefully it seems oh it stays there
yeah what happens in arizona doesn't
stay in arizona when it comes to our
border it really does spread across the
country so it's important for the whole
country but we need to work with and if
i were governor right now unfortunately
i won't be governor until january of 23
tim
but
this problem can't go on until then
we're not going to have a country and so
we need to do something now and our
current governor needs to work with some
of the friendly red states and say hey
can can we borrow some of your law
enforcement bring them down help us
protect the border and let's start
building the wall right now what is joe
biden going to do come down and arrest
us i was watching a clip from cnn that
was on reddit and it was a a panel with
a bunch of trump supporters i guess
and it was making fun of them because
this little old lady said three million
illegal immigrants voted in the election
and it was a i can't remember who i
think may it wasn't dana bash i can't
remember who was uh interviewing him but
cnn woman she goes uh
you really believe three million illegal
immigrants voted in the election she's
like yes you know the president
encouraged him to vote blah blah and
here are these two groups of people
saying things and cnn she's like i
looked it up it's fake news you know
whatever it didn't happen i get it and
i'm sitting there like they're both
missing the mark the fact of the matter
is
every single illegal immigrant in this
country adds voting power
and does impact the presidential
election quite simply when we vote for
the president we are not voting as
individuals in a popular vote we are
having our states do an electoral vote
electoral votes are based on
congressional districts congressional
districts are apportioned based on the
total population not total citizen
population that means if arizona sees a
massive influx of non-citizens into
dense urban areas when they do the
census the dense urban areas get extra
congressional seats based on
non-citizens which adds equivalent
voting power in presidential elections
so i believe there were some estimates
that california in the past got one
extra electoral vote because of their
illegal immigrant population so no i
don't i don't believe illegal immigrants
are showing up in mass by the millions
to vote in the elections and no one's
catching it but i do think it's fairly
obvious whether you want to argue that
or not the point is outside of it
we know that if they do the census and
there's no citizenship question
then you are going to get congressional
seats that are being report uh uh
allocated specifically to non-citizens
so yeah they're effectively getting
their voting power in and president
trump wanted that question to be asked
are you a citizen and the courts ruled
against him
on that so i mean
we we had people voting who shouldn't
have voted
i believe in arizona and we had the
forensic audit and we the to me the
biggest problem it was it was
multi-layered what happened there you
know you just look at the the mail-in
ballots that didn't have a signature had
a little scribble
they weren't checking they weren't
verifying that yeah we're verifying it
and when you look at the number of
questionable ballots out there
compared to what the margin of the
victory was
there are way too many questionable
ballots to say that one person won and
one didn't this is what we actually
heard from matt brainer we've had him on
the show several times and he he's never
come out and and at least to us
made a definitive and hard statement
he's always said there are questions
based on uh uh you know how many votes
how do i know how to phrase it properly
i don't want to put words in his mouth
i'm trying to be very careful for his
sake but he was basically saying we
can't know
these things need to be looked into and
investigated because these right here
are red flags well if one person won and
i'm trying to be very careful because i
know youtube has a bunch of issues if
one person won by 10
457 votes and you have
hundreds of thousands or even 100 000 or
200 000 questionable ballots that could
have been
problematic and i'm being careful with
my words here
um then you're looking at wow 200 300
000 problematic votes and the margin of
victory was just over ten thousand so
issues issues how do you resolve
something like that like did are the
courts in arizona going to go and and
and investigate this i know there was a
big audit well i am i am for expanding
the forensic audit to all 15 counties
because even counties and here's the
deal
trump
supporters would never want trump to win
in a questionable questionable way
i don't i i want my guy to win of course
but i don't want him to win
at the risk of throwing our elections
into tumult and i want secure elections
that we can have faith in and that's
what i plan to do as
as governor i think that's one of the
reasons i got president trump's
endorsement he knows that we're not
going to sweep 2020 under the rug we're
going to take a look at it we have this
forensic audit that was done really well
despite what the fake media and the
corrupt media is reporting
and we're going to take everything that
we found from there and we're going to
fix it i'm a mom so i do lists and i
check them off and to do list
and it might not happen before the 2020
because i don't think we have enough
strong leaders in office who are going
to say you know what i don't care what
they say about me we're doing this for
our country to keep our republic
together we're doing it for arizona i'll
tell you i think uh
republicans need to be working on ground
game and looking at the laws that were
changed looking at policies across the
country so uh we had a lot were changed
in arizona leading up
leading up to the election a lot of laws
were changed by people who had no right
to change them the legislature is the
only one that has the right to change
election laws and all of these people
adrian fontes and all these local people
usurped the legislature to change
election laws that's illegal i think we
saw that in georgia i think we uh in
pennsylvania was interesting because i i
want to be careful not you know we've
talked a bit about it so for people who
aren't familiar we'll give you i'll give
you the context but you know
pennsylvania a year before the election
i think was october the republican
legislature voted for universal mail in
ballots and initially they were going to
call it i think um i think they're going
to say universal absentee or something
and then they realized it was
unconstitutional because the
pennsylvania constitution specifically
says you can't do this so they stopped
pulled it back halfway and then changed
some warning and pushed it through and a
lower court judge actually said hey that
looks like it's not constitutional when
it went to the higher court in
pennsylvania they said you're too late
have a nice day they didn't even rule on
it so i think the big the big play for
republicans coming into 22 there's two
two big things i think people need to do
looking into everything you've said for
one i definitely think matters but in
order to get to the point where you can
get that investigation and make sure
you're getting legitimate information
getting a legitimate investigation not
that i'm not saying the friends of god
it didn't happen i'm saying the power to
actually look through these things enact
things
primaries
make sure the establishment republicans
if you're voting republican aren't the
ones who are going to get back in and
then just jam everything up
voting locally
so people who are in arizona need to be
thinking about their state senators
their state representatives
their governor school board school board
for sure because i you look at a lot of
what happened when it comes to the
presidential election and i tell people
this
a time it was time magazine i think
right for the shadow campaign to fortify
the election there's an article they
wrote and they talked about lays it out
they talk about changing laws they talk
about changing rules they talk about
ground game they talk about activists
going out and i'm like that all right
there is laid out for you
if you want to address those things you
need local politicians you need state
level politicians you need to win your
legislature you need to win your
governorship and you need to win your
uh even your council your school board
especially but a lot of people are just
looking at congress thinking that if i
vote for my rep in congress it's going
to affect these things that ain't it
it's all it's it's from the ground up
basically we look at and we're seeing it
um we're seeing huge in arizona right
now with school boards and i mean admit
i i thought i was a really informed
voter for years i've always voted since
i was 18 years old
and but i never paid enough attention to
school boards and we have a situation in
scottsdale where we have a 27 year old
guy
unmarried no children living with his
parents who's on the school board making
a lot of decisions about our children
and it was just revealed in the last
month or so that
he a computer at his home was keeping a
dossier on
40 plus nearly 50 parents who
had the you know audacity to step up at
school board meetings and say hey wait a
minute what's being taught to our kids
now you know 2020 woke up a lot of
parents when they walked past the zoom
camera and heard what was being taught
to their kids and they went
what the heck is going on here and so
they start asking questions and
this guy who's the president of the
school board again 27 no kids in the
school district starts keeping a file on
them but i mean what was he doing was he
like stalking pulling a background
information he's saying his dad did it
on the computer at his home pulling up
all of the people who spoke out the moms
pulling up very detailed information
about the family so it would be if you
spoke out and you had a divorce in your
family the divorce decree now this took
somebody to go down to the
uh courts pull a thousand page divorce
decree a lot of private information this
is one of my friends whose divorce
decree was pulled up information that
even their children didn't know because
you know when you have little ones
sometimes you don't want them knowing
all of the nitty gritty details of what
led and what was he going to use this
for um a single mom who was a nurse
her information was pulled up her
nursing license number and then there
was a new complaint against her nursing
license and i hope to god it didn't come
from this guy here she is trying to make
a living put food on the table for her
little one and someone is
really cyber stalking and bullying her
um it had photographs of little girls 8
10 13 year old they were children of the
parents who spoke out
um pis were were hired to follow some of
the parents and get license plate
numbers one woman said all of her assets
were listed
this is crazy stuff one mom said for the
school board yeah so he's collecting a
dossier to go out who knows what he's
going to do with it to go after these
people to sue them we don't know but
when they discovered it accidentally
they were shocked imagine going in here
and going whoa my divorce decree my bank
what the heck my children's pictures so
it's really scary one woman said they
had created a um meme i guess you call
it i'm going to sound really old
she said meant to make her look racist
it was a picture of her
this mother and it was shared with they
he shared it with all the parents all
the all the school uh teachers at school
it was a picture of her next to a
slave hanging from a tree this is a
mother who has he was trying to paint
her as racist she'd done nothing wrong
except ask about her kids curriculum
i i get you know angry and emotional
when i think about it because it is our
right as parents to question that and
not be doxed harassed have pis come
after us and have a dossier collected
how is it that a guy with no kids is on
the school board well here's why and
thank you for bringing me back to the
story yeah i got you i got triggered
there
he ran unopposed nobody was running
and this is where what i'm getting to we
think we're all involved and we know i'm
gonna know i'm gonna run for congress
i've researched everybody these are the
people i want but we have to go down the
ballot school board is the most
important race because this is these are
the people affecting what our kids are
learning and now we're seeing what years
and years and decades of bad curriculum
have done we're seeing it churned out in
our schools and this anti-american
you know studies that the american
history is now anti-american history and
it's pretty scary so which generation is
at fault was it was it the boomers who
were not teaching kids proper values
which resulted in teachers so so i'll
put it this way you've got teachers like
this guy he's 27 right so he's a what is
he an older millennial and they have
these wacky views many of them are
communist many of them hate america many
of them are overtly racist
identitarian so they're being taught by
like the like boomers how did how did
this ideology become
so prevalent among you know the
millennial generation to the point where
now in schools teachers have are
believing this insanity i i mean i grew
up in the 70s and 80s my dad was a
public school teacher taught history
government he was a football coach he
would be
horrified i mean i'm glad he's not with
us today because he would be so
horrified by what's being taught i don't
know where it started to seep in
i really don't but i think it i mean i i
know that a lot of people probably your
age i mean what were you taught tim how
was history portrayed to you i uh it's
funny because i always see these things
on twitter where
these these woke millennials are like
they don't actually teach people in
school about slavery jim crow and the
trail of tears and i'm like i was taught
all of that like i don't understand like
uh i went to but were you taught it
where where you continued along beyond
that i mean obviously those are really
deep scars and very difficult moments in
our history but was it continued as
history continued to be taught and the
years moved on and you're moving through
like you know what happened in our
history was it always that
the european settlers or are always the
oppressor or people who are white or the
oppressor never and it was interesting
though because it was very eurocentric
history of course i mean we're a nation
that has founding in european
colonization but i remember um you know
being taught about christopher columbus
when i was little can i tell the story
how he discovers america and my mom was
like leif eriksen was here first
norwegian right uh yeah are you
norwegian no okay my dad my dad's
norwegian he's like leif erickson not
christopher columbus
but hold on and then my mom was like
there were already people here
like the native americans crossing the
bering strait so who discovered it to
say it's discovered is to be from a
perspective of europe now the
interesting thing is that perspective i
get from my mom she never said and
that's why white people are evil no she
was like well the european historical
perspective is how they came to discover
america but there were other people here
they have their histories and it was
just like ah interesting it's very you
know pragmatic and more objective but
what you're getting from the woke
millennial generation and these teachers
is and because they came here and it was
conquest these people are all evil
colonization is evil it's white
supremacy it's it's you know and where
does it end i mean we keep teaching this
what is the goal of that i think it's
the division
i think
i view it like fire it's consuming it's
destroying and it has no real
directional end you know uh if you look
at
traditional american values it was
moving in in a direction towards
something civil rights emerged you ended
up with um
i mean civil rights is a really great
example of this innocent until proven
guilty this is this is something that's
rooted much very much in the bible and i
know a lot of atheists and a lot of you
know leftists don't want to recognize
that uh that's where it came it really
did the story of sodom and gomorrah and
lot uh so you actually had over a long
period of time the bad things that came
with these traditions being removed as
people don't tolerate the violence
anymore a good example is how dueling
eventually stopped happening because the
younger generation uh there was one
young generation that said hey you guys
just killed each other over a fight
that's dumb yeah and so they stop doing
it then you end up we end up as a
country that starts with slavery but you
know within 80 or so years we're like
we're going to fight a bloody death you
know to make sure that we end this then
you get civil rights we were actually
doing a really great job but a lot of it
was rooted in a christian moral
framework whether people like it or
don't that's literally the framework
that was you know the judeo-christian
tradition but now we have with wokeness
something completely separate from that
moral framework and they don't believe
in innocent until proven guilty at all i
mean we just had a story of a black
lives matter activist his name is cortez
rice showing up at the judge's house
apartment in the dante wright case he's
since he subsequently been arrested i
don't i don't know the 50 000 bail he
went to the home it was reported or at
least he was trying to i don't know
exactly where the judge lives but he was
filming himself do it they do not
believe in the values that you know have
been established here in the united
states so what i see is that kind of
behavior is
very much in line with what we saw with
the communists but also the fascists and
it was david graber the uh the late
david david graber who said that a sect
of the left has has embraced the
fascistic ideology there is no truth but
power and so now what we're seeing is
when i i have to talk about how there's
two different realities uh in the united
states and that's why left and right
seem to be meaningless like you know
economically i'm actually rather left i
think universal basic health care things
like these very nuanced we have to get
into an argument about them but uh
however i find myself hanging out with
independents libertarians conservatives
and disaffected liberals because i think
what separates us from you know the the
rival i guess what you call the left is
our moral framework tends to be rooted
very much in judeo-christian values even
though we aren't theistic i'm not a
religious person but bill maher is a
good example his values free speech
innocent until proven guilty these
classically or traditionally liberal
values are rooted in judeo-christian uh
moral frameworks that doesn't mean you
have to agree with you know the the
bible or but if we tear that apart then
we don't have a country and then we have
chaos but you can be democrat you can be
libertarian you can be conservative you
can be republican whatever but we all
have to agree that the freedom of speech
innocent until proven guilty that the
system we have which the u.s
constitution is the greatest system out
there i mean there's nothing better and
if we can agree on that but what's
happening now is you have people who are
on the left and i worked in in
in media for 30 years 27 in arizona i
know journalists who are for censorship
that is shocking this is this is the
craziest thing to me they're they're for
and it's like the first amendment
freedom of speech no they're for
censorship there's a group called free
press
and i've i knew several people from free
press and i remember when they banned
alex jones free press.net was advocating
before he got men they were advocating
for his censorship and i said i was like
what's the name of your organization
again free press and i was like and what
is this campaign we're trying to get a
media organization banned
it's like
the local paper a journalist and i'm
using that he's an activist write
articles about me and suggest that i
have my twitter page taken down i can't
remember what it was was it over the
something like talking about ivermectin
hydroxychloroquine
and suggest that i have my that i'd be
completely banned from social media and
this is a a journalist
to me that's shocking i mean and we're
talking about going on here the things
you can say the things you can't say
we're in an era right now where
censorship is happening we have to live
under it unfortunately i want to ban
censorship in arizona when i'm governor
and there will be hell to pay if a
company tries to keep you from having
free speech i mean free speech is
absolutely essential if you look at
progression of humanity it happens under
freedom and i think america represents
that freedom obviously it doesn't have a
perfect record obviously the
military-industrial complex has caused a
lot of global harm i would argue but
if speaking representatively america
stands for freedom and to me you have to
destroy this larger experiment this
larger idea because when you do you get
rid of something that is extremely rare
in human history if you look at human
history this ability to be able to
defend yourself this ability to be able
to say whatever you want is extremely
rare and if they destroy the founding of
this country that was based on those
principles and those ideas they could
destroy that freedom that also comes
with it and i think they have been
successful in many ways already doing it
uh without many people even realizing
well let's think about freedom of
religion we had our churches shut down
did you ever think i mean i'm probably
the oldest one here walmart was open but
you couldn't go to church yeah i mean i
never thought a day would come when
churches were shut down in this country
whether you go to church or not isn't
that something that is a main tenant of
this country the first amendment the
very first freedom yeah i think about
like what things could get changed if we
were to lose the government in some
crazy like things like murdering might
now become like things we think of as
like just inherently illegal and wrong
without question could then become
totally normal normalized in a new
regime
in portland when aaron dowson was shot
in the chest the uh leftists cheered and
you saw what happened at chazz i mean
people got killed at chad one of my
staffers lived in chess he was embedded
in chazz and the way we protect children
he wasn't he's not for that
he was in as an outsider going in there
to check it out i'd like to i like to
say to uh people who've never met luke
i'll be like luke's been epstein island
and then they go like whoa he was a
visitor it's not good at parties people
were like what and then people started
looking at me like were you the guy that
went there after it was closed down and
got the video yeah yeah i went there
when i said why didn't you tell me that
when i met luke because if i walked up
to you and said this guy's been
abstinent
creeper or something and it happens all
the time
was that the time that jeffrey epstein
was there and he drove up in the little
well there was there was there was a
drone footage of allegedly someone that
looked like epstein in the golf cart and
when i saw that after he allegedly you
know off to himself i was like i need to
go there i need to fact find this i need
to verify this so that's when me and my
friends went to the island crashed it
and tried to get as much publicity about
this event as much as possible because
no one was talking about it in the
corporate media but also online all
online there's this there's this hashtag
epstein didn't kill himself there was
people asking questions there's people
making memes they're they were making
songs they were making t-shirts they
were demanding to know what was going on
here and that voice wasn't heard other
than of course independent media and as
independent media i decided we need to
do this we need to step things up you
guys are the new mainstream media and
then and i mean that in a good way the
mainstream media now is the alternative
independent media and that's taking over
thank god
let me let me ask you about this uh you
worked for 22 years
in like uh your your mainstream media i
guess 30 years mainstream media 30 years
right 27 years covering arizona as a
journalist and an anchor and 22 of those
years my last 22 for the fox affiliate
when did it go
wrong
and i think the media really you know
there were always places you could work
that were more liberal i mean obviously
cnn crazy um but you know you also say
fox is more
reasonable if you're conservative and at
least they i i believe it was great a
great place to work but i think when
president trump came on the scene
candidate trump in 2015 when he came
down the escalator that's when i noticed
people in media and i'm talking all of
the networks starting to really lose it
even people that i thought were really
reasonable i'm like why are you so upset
about this guy he has a right to run
he meets the qualifications to run what
who cares if he runs right but it was a
complete as as i like to say he cro he
cracked the
shells off the nuts do you think that it
was they didn't like trump or that they
wanted hillary to win so bad that they
didn't like whoever was coming and it
just turned out to be donald trump then
they turned him into a boogie man
i don't know i wonder if they had a deep
fear that oh my gosh this guy could win
and our and our lady won't win the one
one we want i don't know why i can't put
my finger on was there a feeling at fox
or anywhere that you were that there was
like a
an agenda to get a certain person
elected well let me put it this way when
you work in media 90
maybe 95 percent are
liberal for sure and a big chunk of them
are leftist socialists
so
we know you know how we feel about our
candidates if if all of a sudden a
newsroom was 95
hardcore conservative it would change
the way things work but with so 95 being
liberal they're like oh gosh we don't
like this guy did you see around the
time when the uh
so it was around 2016 you started to
feel like things were changing it was it
just went really crazy when trump came
around and then i really think it went
to a whole new level with covet and i i
believe that initially the 15 days to
slow the spread i think where we were
all kind of like whoa
what's going on here okay i'm willing to
slow things down for 15 days if we're
gonna i mean i was i was
reading the news and believing it we're
seeing about you come out who's this new
scientist guy oh my gosh we gotta wipe
our groceries down
put our masks on i mean i i was i
believed it all be afraid of our fellow
neighbors and people to be afraid and i
work in a neighborhood and i i did a
prageru video and and i really kind of
lay out what happened in the media and
what brought me to walking away from a
very large comfortable paycheck
and um you know great benefits to just
walk away from that it has to be
something pretty bad did you notice
around this time that younger people
were coming into the workforce like were
you seeing more millennials join your
your office your newsroom yeah and and i
talk a little bit about that there was a
shift in and and this also plays into
how media changed there was a shift in
losing some of the older more
established reporters and journalists
and i think it's because corporate media
took over there's been a lot of regional
news
you know a company here and a company
there owned it and then it became now
five or six corporations own all the
media they bought up all these smaller
outlets maybe you had a a family who
owned three stations they bought that up
and they just started accumulating more
and more media over the years and this
happened in the 80s and 90s and when
they accumulated more they wanted to
pare down the bottom line so let's say
tim you're a you know 50 year old
seasoned journalist who's been at the
station covering the you know the city
you live in for a long time and they go
tim
you know you're making a hundred and
twenty thousand and we're we're hiring
people right out of this college asu for
forty thousand
we can hire three people for the price
of you
and they start making your life
miserable and
you know saying no to every story you
want to cover and pretty soon tim goes i
don't want to work for this and guess
what those three millennials who've got
journalism degrees
are very yeah air quotes right there
theater degrees they're going social
justice their warriors to be communists
yeah and i'll tell you my thoughts on
that and this is what this is why i
asked um you know based on what i had
seen when i was working for some of
these companies it was when they were
bringing in more and more young people
younger millennials is when they started
to have a bigger influence on the
culture
and what i discovered when i was uh you
know managing you know uh uh i was never
a manager but when i was
working with younger people you're a
manager now definitely now i mean i'm
the ceo of a company but uh not that
it's a big company but um what i found
is
many of these young people had never had
a job in their lives right they had
never worked and so what happens is they
go to school from kindergarten all the
way up until they're 22 or 24.
they've always been told what to do and
by someone in charge
so they have no uh
they not within them they do not have
the i'll figure this out
attitude they're not entrepreneurs
they're not driven
quite literally i experienced when
working with these people is they'd come
up to you and say just tell me what to
do and i would say you need to figure it
out like here's your problem that's on
you i i did not hire you so that i could
solve problems for you they were given
freedom as a child because of fear that
the media put in oh my gosh don't let
your kid ride their bike there could be
a bad guy who wants to nab him and there
are bad guys out there don't get me
wrong but we when i was growing up we
had tons of freedom begin my my parents
would say get the heck out of the house
and don't come back in until we call you
and no matter we would go out and play
and
maybe that's the secret because i had
that too they didn't have any of that
freedom to grow up in and learn all
these little things and now cps is
showing up at people's homes because
they had their children walk home from
school that was literally a case that
happened here in the united states yeah
i think also i mean we talk about the
corporate media a lot but i think we
also have to acknowledge big tech social
media and the algorithms i think play
more of an imperative role to the
development of young children especially
with parents literally throwing their
phone at a baby just to keep them
occupied showing them their latest kind
of hollywood propaganda uh you know that
usually probably could have been
produced by someone like harvey
weinstein or some other sicko or creepo
uh and and i think we have to understand
when there's algorithms they are
literally shaping people's perceptions
of reality and when they do that they
could shape your reality to whatever
they want and i think they did it they
did it in such a twisted way where we're
seeing record high suicides record high
depressions record high mental health
issues and i think that's done
deliberately because when you have
someone who's not happy when you have
someone who's not healthy they're going
to be someone that's going to be
dependent on someone who's going to be
that dependent the state the government
rather than of course the parents the
family members the individuals who are
standing up for each other as
responsible human beings we don't have
that anymore we have the state as the
mom and dad of people's lives and we saw
so many of people move into having the
state control their life during covet
they left the job had to close down they
left they're getting paid they're
sitting home and now the people who got
back out there and got to work
are being told
get the
job if i can say that or lose your job
with the mandates that are out right now
and so this is uh we're taking the final
group of people who are the working
engine in this society and they're
trying to get them to to walk away from
their job
and it's really frightening and then and
then what what do you do if they say get
the job or leave your your job and you
say no i'm not going to get that i don't
want it whatever the reason being you
you want your freedom you walk away now
you're on the system
they're destroying the working class
are you are you familiar with the band
the offspring
no you've never heard of it so they're
actually can you sing can you sing a few
uh lines
separated you know that one from the 90s
maybe maybe you know uh i definitely
could and i'd like to and i actually uh
i don't
anyway anyway
uh they're a very big band they're very
big they were they were super huge in
the 90s they had
yeah yeah they had the biggest
the largest record sales or most amount
of records sold for any independent
label ever now i'm embarrassed that i
don't i probably will hear you should
you know the song pretty fly for a white
guy it's a great song no uh what else i
don't know
uh anyway
they had their drummer was actually
kicked out of the band because he had
guillain-barre syndrome
and
you can't get the vac well the doctor at
least said i you're not a candidate for
the you know you can't get this because
if you get you if you have
guillain-barre syndrome they're worried
you can get nerve issues right and so
when uh i guess when when he talked to
the band or i don't know exactly what
happened all i know is ultimately he
ends up kicked out of the band for that
reason
became kind of a big issue in the news a
little bit for those that are interested
in music but that one to me was kind of
the most insane now i was on joe rogan's
show
and he was saying to me that well look
man that's tough because venues won't
let you perform with someone who's
unvaccinated and i was like i hear you i
hear you
so
this band the offspring is a business
they have an employee
they need to go to venues to sell their
product and many of these venues are
like if you're not vaccinated you can't
come in
it's insane to me that someone based uh
i mean
first of all it's insane to me there's a
mandate period
but to actually tell someone who's got a
medical condition you will lose your job
because of your medical condition i
thought that was illegal and you know
look it's a it's a clever workaround i
suppose if the venue won't let you in
the band can be like we're not letting
you go you just can't work for us
anymore but if it were me and this is
why i i have uh uh i don't know the
story from you know the the main guys at
the offspring dexter holland's the main
guy and then you know his guitarist
noodles i don't know what their side of
the story is but based on what i've
heard
if this dude said look my doctor says i
can't get it and they said get out
you're fired that's scumbaggery that is
that is that is that is wrong you know
what you do travis tritt is that is that
the country star who said you know i'm
not going to perform at these arenas
that are mandating um my fans come and
show any vaccine mandate or show any
vaccine passport or that my my staff my
band members
we're in tough times right now we're in
times right to make difficult choices
and that might mean walking away from a
paycheck or walking away from a payday
for this band you know what you know
when if we don't start standing up and
doing the right thing what's the next
step
jim brewer also did that as well yeah
jim brewer also did that i just want i
just want to point out again distress
i don't know exactly what went on with
this band and i want to be careful
because for all i know like they were
throwing pies at each other and people
get five people get fired sometimes but
if uh operating under the assumption
that there is a band worth millions of
dollars if you google search the network
of net worth of dexter holland it's 80
million dollars that doesn't mean it
really is but the dude is particularly
wealthy
you've got a drummer i think who played
with them for over a decade i think like
14 years
and all of a sudden this thing happens
where it's like venues aren't gonna let
you in
it is mind-blowing to me and this is
this is where i say like economically
i'm probably lefty i would never i would
never do that to somebody if if i had a
company that was worth 80 million
dollars and we had we had cash and and
the government came down i would do two
things the first i'd say then we will
only play venues
that don't have this
and if for some reason we have no choice
because there's a city with fans and
that and we have to play
i will find a session drummer for this
show buddy you've been with us for over
a decade i will not let you down i could
i can't a fathom a reality in which
there are people who are like i may be
worth 80 million dollars but screw you
you're fired because of because of what
they're doing with this mandate that to
me is sickening well and that's a good a
solution okay if we have to perform
we've got fans who want to see us we
have our band you know we bring somebody
in you pay the guy who's part of the
band for how many years
and then
you don't fire him
people are going to be sued later
because we're going to find out this is
all unconstitutional yeah and i think
that's why and this band has to
someday and i know i don't know if
you're religious
meet their maker
and you're going to meet your maker and
you're going to say i did the right
thing or did the wrong thing
or you're going to look at your kids one
day and say when this country hopefully
we're saved you're going to say i was
part of saving this country this is
supposed to be a punk band
and it is exactly this is of punk it
sounds like a personality issue
it's just too too weird to not be i
don't know man after uh 14 15 years yeah
so i don't believe that but don't these
bands make all their money by performing
live now i heard that you know with the
record labels you're not making what you
think you these guys would make so they
have to perform live some of the people
from the 90s got fathered and
grandfathered in and they're still
raking
wouldn't it be so much cooler to say
you know what we we're going to go to
this arena and now screw it we're not
going there right we're going to
somebody find a big field what did tim's
house out here with all this land and
we're going to do our freedom stand
right we've got 50 acres we're going to
free domestic that's what we're doing
you know and that's why we luke came up
with the name this is that freedom stand
are you holding concerts there we are
going to that's great well hopefully
it's west virginia so nobody really
cares anything you want you almost can't
well when we drove out here i was like
is this a blair witch project yeah
what's going on here we are a few miles
like that
we are a few miles away from where they
filmed blair which apparently that's
what i was told you know i can't believe
how thick the forest is out here that's
great i mean you can't even walk through
it probably without hitting a tree
we had a bear attack we had we had a
bear so we have uh a chicken coop it's
very nice
bigger than my house no no that's the
that's new chicken city okay the ruins
of old chicken city are in front the
rubble and yeah it's the old but we had
a bear i guess look with the lockdowns
there's less refuse animals become more
desperate and a bear actually this is
basically our front porch so you have a
front porch and then to the left is
where the coop is and a bear came and
actually tried ripping it open and we we
had you know people around us being like
there was a bear through the
neighborhood and we saw the metal ripped
off and we were like that was the bear
so you know uh
where i'm going with this is
guns
because uh out here in the middle of
nowhere you shoot the bear is it no
sound okay no no but that's where i'm
going the point i'm making is
to to wrap up the you know the other
we're talking about music and freedom
my attitude is i will not go to these
venues in in new york uh jack murphy a
good friend of uh a good friend of ours
and
end of the show he's been doing these
events and he said we're gonna do ours
on the other side of the river because
they've got vaccine mandates in new york
and we can do it at a venue with that
one
i i i believe
maybe you can't play a stadium because
they're all mandating it but stand up
for something right so for us we have
this space and we can do almost anything
so we'll have a shooting range and we're
going to be putting on concerts and
we're going to be hosting events that's
great where we can just say you know
screw it there's also pork fest up in
new hampshire that has you know it's all
about freedom and they've got the free
state project a bunch of bitcoin
conferences there's a bunch of free
festivals there's a bunch of people
coming together there is a mass
awakening with protests happening all
over the world in huge record numbers
that are absolutely incredible to see
filling the streets for blocks on down
and i just had this idea randomly tim i
think we should do a parody of the blair
witch project we go to the woods that
they filmed it in but we have firearms
so if someone messes with us we just
shoot him and then that's the end of the
movie it's like okay that's that's what
happens when you're armed when you're
able to defend yourself
you know hurt you or kill you right we
wouldn't have had a two-hour terrifying
movie it'll be like two minutes long oh
we're walking in the woods oh there's
someone trying to hurt us trying to kill
him oh it'll be like that famous scene
from the movie where luke's got the
camera pointed up his nose and he's like
looking around he goes i think you need
a wide cam for that one he's got a white
cam and then he's like i hear something
tim do you hear that what's who is there
and then lugos hold on and then he just
unholsters the shine arm and he's like
don't move ah he's armed don't move
don't make me put it down put it down
he's running away
all right anyway what were you talking
about tim you're telling me a joke
uh no but
moving on from that i'm curious about uh
i'm
you you're probably pro 2a across the
board absolutely yeah let's talk about
guns the thing is i i know people who
never even owned a gun who are now they
have guns they've got ammo they're
stocking up and what's happened the last
couple years has woken up a lot of
people
and uh i'm not only my whole family
knows how to you know shoot and all of
that we do you know target practice
outside and at our gun club but i think
it's imperative to have the second
amendment the only thing keeping us
america and free right now is our second
amendment i was i was going to most
important where on the republican
political spectrum are you are you in
the mitt romney authoritarian status
sector or are you in the ron paul i
believe in freedom sector where's that
sword over there somebody where where on
what level are you uh let me just put it
this way um i'm endorsed by
let's say ron paul is a hundred mitt
romney is a zero on the freedom scale
what's your number i'm a hundred okay
i'm a hundred i am a trump republican as
i like to say um i'm endorsed by
president trump proud of that by
congressman gosar by rick grinnell
michael flynn mike lindell
one of my favorite patriots so i love
i have the uh the america first movement
well trump i would i would say was like
a to my opinion my perspective like a 45
35 i mean he did he did the bump stock
ban he made a lot of incredulous moves
against the second amendment personally
oh you were talking only on the senate
no no in freedom all just freedom in
general i am a hundred percent pro-2a
and and as i say my my stance on it it
shall not be infringed i will never sign
any
legislation that would infringe
whatsoever
now on will you work towards repealing
unconstitutional gun laws absolutely
that's you know but i think people think
they go oh the governor has all the
governor has all the power to do
everything you have to have legislators
working with you you know this is how
the system works so we'd have to and
arizona is a very free uh state when it
comes to second amendment i think is
probably the most free you know we've
had open carry texas didn't even have
open carry until last year yeah you're
right right
lauren roberts arizona isn't she no no
she colorado yeah okay okay that was um
yeah what about heavy weapons
how big how do you feel like how how
powerful weapon do you think it should
be legal for someone to carry are you
actually asking like joe biden saying
you need to have a fighter jets if
you're really going to take on these
yeah like because people usually are
losing to the taliban
next week
this is something tim quotes from time
to time
warships under the second amendment like
privateers i mean then the government
would conscript them to go fight for
them but like private citizens could own
warships so should a private citizen be
able to own a small nuclear device
nuclear bomb
rocket launchers not for nuclear weapons
i'm not for private rocket launchers
um the
tough questions these are tough
questions i don't think i i am i am for
a you know there's probably any weapon
that any any gun i mean i'm i'm pro 2a
so i i don't know rocket launchers
more powerful so it's important
is a rocket launcher a firearm
definitely it's a ballistic right to
bear arms by aaron it is arms
and so this is an issue
my attitude is private citizens should
be allowed to own rocket launchers
private citizens should be able to be
allowed to own bazookas well if you read
the second amendment it talks about you
know it's not about hunting and it's not
about target shooting right it's about
protecting against tyranny which well
it's it's it's about predicting
everything uh a free state
it you know uh it requires the the
people to i'm not quoting cinnamon but
i'm saying it's it says you know uh
can you who can verbally well it's a
well-armed militia and
i wanna i just wanna i wanna know
yeah i want to read it specifically okay
i'll read it to you if you need it right
here
a well-regulated militia thank you being
necessary to the security of a free
state the right of the people to keep
and bear arms shall not be in fringe the
reason i want to get it verbatim
is that
uh
securing a free state what does that
mean well can you have a free state if a
bunch of bears attack your city
no no of course a lot of them so it's
not about one thing it's about
everything and so there's been a lot of
people who have said it's specifically
about when your governor government
becomes tyrannical and i'm like no no no
no it's not specifically about that it
doesn't include that it's also about if
a foreign adversary seeks to invade your
country and everyone's armed with the
teeth and they're like there's a gun
behind or if that foreign corporation
hijacks your monetary supply and prints
your economy into oblivion you're that's
threatening the security of your free
state right there what happens if
someone comes to your door and tries to
pull your family out and put you in uh a
quarantine camp
oh yeah that's when things go go reel
dark this is well and i think this is
why the difference between australia
there's a million differences in america
and i think this is why we haven't had
more
strong restrictions placed against us
because especially in the state like
arizona you know behind any door someone
might have a gun probably does you can
see the way the australian cops move too
they have no fear no fear and it's and
what people need to understand it's not
an issue of assuming that australians
would be running out the door and just
firing wildly it's like ian mentioned
it's the fear when the police broke down
the door of briana taylor's house you
know the story about brennan taylor her
boyfriend fired around in the direction
of the door striking a police officer in
the leg that was ruled justified and the
charges were dropped because if you
break in someone's door they could be
armed police in america know this and
that means regardless of what the law is
they have to contend with the fact
there's an armed population it doesn't
mean that there's going to be a bunch of
right-wing nut jobs taking over with
guns everywhere and screaming and you
know when when the government does
something wrong it means the government
is scared to make certain moves because
it's not about whether or not there's an
armed militia showing up at your door
and saying we hereby you know declare
it's about the fact that
you tried to enforce a red flag law this
happened i think it was in maryland and
the guy showed up with a gun fought the
cops and the cops had to shoot and kill
him the police understand that when you
go to a door you're not going to get
someone saying okay you might get a
crazy person or not even a crazy person
a scared person yes granny taylor's
boyfriend who just said someone's
breaking into my home fired hit the cop
in the leg hey that's america baby in
australia again like ian said the cops
are fearless they know they have nothing
to worry about there's a video out of
australia where they kick the door and
they walk in start grabbing people
throwing them around i'm like that can't
happen here in america to the same
degree certainly there are no knock
warrants it will never happen
there's their cops breaking into
people's maybe uncertainty they were
breaking into businesses a few months
ago and shutting them down but not like
that and not yeah like that yeah like
that there was a video where was this
video i remember seeing video footage in
new jersey there was a lady who was in
her own private shop doing her own thing
uh and and she was making baskets i
believe if i believe the story was was
correctly coming off fresh of my mind
police officers literally broke down her
door because she was open at her place
of business by herself and told her to
shut down immediately
in north jersey a woman
they closed everyone's businesses and
said you're shut down end of story so
she started live streaming on facebook
if you want to buy any of my products
here's what i have the police showed up
and they said ma'am you need to shut
your store down. and she said what are
you talking about it is shut down i'm
closed and they go no you're posting
things online yep so these things do
happen
not like that i mean not to the scale
that it's no no no no no no no you're
still right new jersey has possibly the
strictest gun laws in the country you
can barely even get a gun in new jersey
and if you can there's crazy rules and
i'm i'm pretty sure you can't have a
weapon in your place of business i could
be wrong unless you are like a security
guard and you've got special
certification it is difficult and
annoying and so the police in new jersey
are substantially less worried about
this is why it's so important to vote
for the right people oh yeah this is
this kind of stuff would not happen in
arizona although our governor shut the
state down twice what was your take on
80 house republicans yesterday voting
for a national
registry of of people who were
vaccinated one of those people was
what's that republican's name with
den crenshaw den crenshaw and eighty
house republicans all voted for this how
would you vote on this particular issue
when it comes to a federal registry of
of people who are vaccinated and what's
your response to like credit shaw for
voting for it you know dan crenshaw used
to be a really big hero and some ways i
think he is a hero i mean he served our
country valiantly and and i think he's a
great guy but some of the things he's
done politically i find alarming
that being one of them
that is a terrible idea now i'd be i'm
running for governor not i'm not running
for congress and so this is something
that would be handled at the federal
level of course um
governor's more important i'm not for
that because as a governor you have the
authority to say we're not going to give
you the database we're not going to give
you the information or the data would
you comply as a governor if there was a
federal vaccine i believe our governor
did a comply with that in order to get
the federal money you had to agree to a
bunch of stuff new hampshire was one of
the states that actually declined uh the
money as a state
would you be willing to do the same
thing as governor i would be okay if it
means we're gonna give out well here's
the deal we did get a lot of money for
and and then they say it's for coveted
relief
but not if i'm gonna have to give up
my my citizens our citizens my fellow
citizens information private information
i'm impressed i i was expecting you to
dance around that that answer because
that's a tough one right well i mean
look what we're where it's getting us we
keep complying with the federal
government and all the things they want
and look where we are right now we're no
more closer to having our freedom back
and when do we stop and say enough is
enough we're not going to comply anymore
we're going to get off the federal tea
take your money and shove it or give us
the money but we're going to spend it
the way we want to speak we're not going
out we're not going to do this that and
the other with your money this is why i
said governor is more important a lot of
people pointed out that if ron desantis
were to run in 2024 florida would lose a
very powerful voice who's doing the
right thing for the citizens and so he's
better
working in florida because he's created
a safe haven essentially for people
they're flocking to florida like crazy
buying up property like crazy why
freedom yeah monoclonal antibodies for
free for people who are sick lowest
covid cases the economy reopened a while
back and rocks you can go there and you
don't even realize there's any restrict
there aren't any restrictions you're
living free and that's what arizona is
going to be so i i tell people too
especially with the legislatures in the
states
if you keep thinking the federal
government is your path to fixing your
problems you are incorrect
ron desantis has proven that abbott to a
certain degree he's not perfect we'll
see he's coming around a little bit yeah
maybe alan west will win because he'll
go you know he'll go much much more like
ron desantis and then uh when it comes
to a potential convention of states
whether it's a good thing or a bad thing
changes can be made if at the state
level people vote for we mention this
across the board and also to this point
district attorneys very important big
issue but i i think and county attorneys
and sheriffs i mean it's
we just have to be educated where we're
going we have to be educated and i
believe the america first movement and
we're going to look at who's funding
these people who are their consultants
people are waking up to and you
mentioned some people who are still
asleep like the
person you talked about uh earlier a
friend of mine yeah we're not going to
name names but who's just completely
unaware of anything but i think a lot of
people are waking up and who were never
involved in politics we're seeing him
when we do events we have a movement
afoot in arizona we do events that
thousands of people come out to we do
rallies and uh you know all kinds of
rallies and people come up to me and say
i am embarrassed to say this but i've
never voted before
and i'm whatever age 50 something and
i'm voting i'm so worried about where
this country i've never been
politically involved but i know who's
running who their consultants are what's
behind them what they believe in so
there's a lot of exciting things happen
i'm actually very hopeful for the future
i was at a trump rally in fort
lauderdale back in 2016 and
every single person that i i talked to
had said like i'm either independent or
i've not voted before and i was like
you're at a republican rally and they're
like trump's different man it's you know
a lot of these people felt like mitt
romney like you saw the disdain that
this luke rutkowski has for the mitt
romneys of this country and yet but
trump supporters do too they despise i
do too i do too and jeff flake and and
john mccain i mean we saw a lot of that
rhino and we have that in arizona we
have a deep deep swamp in arizona
and you know people go don't say rhinos
well that's what they are
actually i disagree um i think you're
the rhino
you want to think i'm the rhino you want
to but you know what you know what i
mean by that that the establishment the
republican party has always been this
feckless weak and you know in my opinion
well well ineffective and what's
happened now is a bunch of people
like trump like desantis and like you
have come in under the umbrella of
republican representing something with
principle and that's why i say i think
you don't want you to do well
i'm the conservative running i'm i'm a
conservative running as a republican
exactly because the republican party i
do believe is the party of trump it's
the trump republican party nowadays that
is america first and you know i talk to
people who are establishment and i
believe i can bring people together i
was a republican looking from the
outside in before i became a politician
thinking that the party you know we had
the rhinos and all of that but i thought
the party was more
congealed and together now that i'm
running i realize it's so fractured
and and i believe we can bring this
party together but the establishment has
to realize america first is here to stay
and they should love that we've brought
people off the sidelines people who you
mentioned at the trump rally that i've
seen at our rallies who've never voted
before but doesn't want them in this
this is what i mean basically when i see
a ton of people who are not republicans
who are joining the republicans but not
because of mitt romney mitt romney
is what what i think of what i think of
republican he repels people from the
party it is a an elitist corporatist
anti-american the koch brothers were all
about the open borders and you know
bringing in cheap labor to exploit even
bernie sanders opposed it trump was not
like the rest of them when he came in so
he was a republican but just in name he
represented something new so to be fair
i would say now the party has become the
party of trump and now that is what it
means to be republican so now i would
say i understand when when you refer to
mccain and these individuals as rhinos
it's because they're the people who
don't actually represent the new the
voter base those who are joining the
party and those who are stepping up it's
huge what's happening though i mean it
is so huge what's happening it's very
exciting we go to events
and they say oh can you come speak at
this republican group or wherever we go
and they call us a couple weeks later
and they say we need to move the
location we we usually get 30 people we
have 130. and this is what we're seeing
everywhere we go people are off the
sidelines they're very excited about our
campaign
and we have a movement we have more
volunteers than any other campaign in
the in the country right now
it took us only three weeks to get our
signatures to get on the ballot
it usually takes to put that in
perspective and i'm i'm new to politics
so i'm like okay three weeks why did it
take us three weeks and they say kerry
no you don't understand
it normally takes candidates nine months
to get them
and they have to pay for them and
sometimes they don't get them at all you
got your you got your signatures in
three weeks it's never been done in the
history of arizona well i mean is is
that people are excited uh
when's the election for arizona august
2nd that's the primary so of of next
year yeah you're getting you're getting
a head start huh we're acting we've been
running since june 1st and we've been
running like it was october of 22. my
staff jokes it's like we're running like
it's the last month leading up to the uh
general election do you have a show
sorry interrupt but do you like a talk
show you'd be great no i need one yeah a
weekly talk show on tv for 30 days i've
thought about doing a podcast so this is
really interesting to watch but i
thought it was easier than this i
thought with just me and a camera and
you would bring somebody else in but
this isn't quite an order what's the
best way to do it because it's not
scripted you you talk from your your
heart you don't talk from talking points
there's nothing scripted here and i i
still got a lot of questions because
there's a lot of people that i know that
are absolutely disenfranchised with the
donald trump party they're they're not
happy that he passed gun control that he
didn't release the cia documents that he
didn't pardon assange that he didn't
support his supporters on january 6th
and some people are saying that this is
just a two-party duopoly what do you say
to people who are disenfranchised with
the left-right political system which
they see as
uh you know two sides of the same coin
that are essentially representing the
special interests
i'm disenfranchised with the two-party
system as well but i think you know i
think president trump did a really good
job and he did what he could we don't
know everything he was up against
i mean he was the first one going in as
an outsider into the swamp and people go
well he hired the wrong people didn't
you know there's a lot of positions you
have to hire and he didn't have the best
people to choose from he's working in
the swamp fouchy and uh he didn't hide
him without cheating and fired fauci
but he had him around him and then
what's that guy with the weird mustache
john bolton oh yeah
i mean
john bolton i mean that to me is not
just bad people that's you really yeah
you have to go in and you got to hire
people though and he didn't make all the
right decisions but i think
i think he uh on all in all i think he
did an amazing job not he's not perfect
you know i love it when people say about
trump i wish his tweets would have been
nice or wish he wouldn't have been so
rough or whatever they say and i think
he's a new yorker the reason we got
somebody who was strong enough to go up
against the system to beat down all of
those what was it 17 18 19 contenders
just one after the next he brought him
down
and go in there and have the
coconuts to do the right thing
is because he was a tough new yorker and
and i i it irritates me when people go i
wish i like you i really like you luke
but i wish you were a little less this
way well we don't get to do that with
human beings are there any moves he did
that you would criticize or you would do
differently than he did whether it's gun
control whether it's
bombing foreign countries is there
anything he did that you will look back
and say i didn't like this i want to do
this if i was in this position i'm not
going to sit here and criticize i mean
look at him and say oh i wish you
wouldn't have done this and that and i
think on average i think president trump
did an amazing job i don't know what he
was up against during each of these
pivotal moments when he was making big
decisions
you know he was really up against a lot
of people media was on him that the
swamp was on him his own party sometimes
was on him and i think he did the best
job he could i think the whole his whole
party was on him the entire time
the established republicans from even
people we think were with him and then
you find out oh my gosh that guy wasn't
with him look at russiagate i mean the
republican party was like well you know
we're gonna have to look into this
instead of just being like shut it down
they controlled they had two years in
control of congress and they and they
they did nothing and i think a lot of
people were disillusioned by it and
trump even said if we lose the house i
will be impeached and my response you
know my attitude then is kind of like
the republican party wasn't doing
anything for trump but i will say i
think it's fair to say
donald trump should have fired fauci and
that's at least one thing you think he
should have done right
yeah he should have but i think
he didn't is because
he probably was um
we we know why it was it was i think it
was kushner
and uh
and and some of his other advisors were
like no no no don't fire him the people
love him the media loves him and we've
had a few of trump's you know uh former
senior individuals and people close to
him who have been like he was getting
advice from them saying not to get rid
of fouchy and he should have
i mean i don't know biden probably would
have hired him back or something but so
what trump was getting bad advice from
that man yeah well and you do take
advice from the people around you i
think that's a smart thing to do and and
maybe his gut was telling him to fire
fouchy but he had a lot of people going
don't do it don't do it and he's like
well maybe i'm having a maybe they're
right or
you know he had some smart people around
him how about firing mark milly
mark milly um who was he what was his
name right mark millie yeah mark the
general general the general millionaire
the one who when they walked out to the
church and then he badmouthed that move
or who said you know we need to look
into white rage or whatever yeah he
should have fired that yes he should
have tried that
well i think he talks about it
the tv generals versus the what does he
call them the ones who who go on all the
talking heads and then the real generals
yeah
he should have parted julian assange on
his way out but i also think why do you
think he didn't do that i think people
need to understand the power of the
bureaucratic state
and
i think ramifications if he did that and
what they might have polled
yes i think peop you know people assume
that once trump got the seed of power
that he could have just you know pen
stroked all of these things he could not
do that and as much as i wanted him ross
ulbricht and julian assange should have
both been pardoned i feel like he was
sitting there and he probably some
there's something we don't know and he
was like
here's who i can pardon here's who i
can't because they will absolutely get
revenge on you
and this is why i say you when you bring
all these things up we don't know all of
the different variables that were of
course play in these so i don't want to
sit and criticize who i think was one of
the greatest presidents or if not the
greatest president of my lifetime i
personally think everyone should be
criticized especially if they're in
power but we're also dealing with a
situation that of course we're looking
from the outside in and that's why i
like talking to individuals getting
their perspective getting their honest
kind of takes on this because and
another thing i wanted to add tim to
your point um he was facing retaliation
about potentially being attacked but the
way donald trump left he was viciously
attacked
and there's a lot of things that
happened he's not in office right now
they're still attacking him and blaming
him for everything well i agree with you
on the instant where it came to the
corporate media they became hysterical
nonsensical and and totally erratic when
it came to any kind of news reporting
surrounding him because every little
thing he did they would trump up as as
as hitler which was absolutely insane it
was nonsensical it was garbled nonsense
and they attacked him on no real
legitimate critical issues that i
believe he should have been criticized
on um and that's why i'm kind of
bringing up the points and starting this
conversation because i want to have an
honest conversation about what i really
think what you really think and and and
who you know who you really are and i
think that's important to trump to lay
out and and you know i think you're
doing it i think it was i i could be
wrong about this sheldon adelson is that
his name the the adolescent adelson yeah
my i could be wrong about this so
definitely factor me but i believe the
reason he hired bolton was because you
know when he got support in his campaign
from adelson
that's how you pronounce it uh that he
was like i want you to hire john bolton
and trump was like okay you know make
sense and bolton is an idiot in my
opinion you know he had this this line i
remember when he said it but it was
during the trump years by this time next
year we'll be celebrating in tehran to
imply the america the united states
would invade iran and then have a stage
set up celebrating their victory in a
year to me is absolutely insane people
don't understand that that iran is not
afghanistan or iraq it is a massive
mountainous developed nation and to have
people who are just fervently like
pro-war so well trump wasn't pro-war but
maybe he felt if he keeps his enemies
close you know
but uh yeah
i think obama thought that too when he
got all those corporate guys to be
surround him
in the first couple weeks of his
administration then he got co-opted i
know trump isn't pro-war but trump was
was
he was lied to for one so i'll give him
that when he was trying to withdraw from
syria and from afghanistan his own
people in the government reportedly were
lying when it came to syria they lied
about the amount of troops we had there
so that trump thought we withdrew
everyone and they kept them in that is
insane that's a lie to the american
people trump still did have commander
raids in yemen arms deals with saudi
arabia what's going on in yemen is
absolutely horrifying and he did fire
what was it 59 tomahawk missiles into
syria and then the media praises him to
a certain degree because of it
so i'll just put it this way i certainly
think trump was surprisingly the best
i've seen in my lifetime in terms of
withdrawing from afghanistan and then
joe biden screws the whole thing up it's
horrible
miserable screw up we've had the media
doesn't talk about it it's a surrender
it's like it's like a two-day story joe
biden is i want to hear the war that
we're winning and he surrenders i think
joe biden may be the worst
maybe it's not fair to say you know the
weapons they left behind were the the
most top grade weapons that are out
there 85 billion dollars worth how come
i'm hearing from my mother they're going
to be used against us that these weapons
are obsolete they're like all the
weapons that they left there aren't even
any good anyway like that's kind of the
spun the media has spawned that's not
true that's not true no they were they
were flying one of the helicopters
around
yeah now they're not gonna be able to
maintain them or anything like that
but
when i saw donald trump
one of the greatest moments of the trump
presidency when he comes out the
helicopter's roaring and the press
assembly's going on and he's like we're
going to do an excellent weapons deal
with saudi arabia it's going to be great
for the economy and all of the anti-war
left just like their jaws hit the floor
like he just came out and admitted
what the united states does
we're gonna go keep the oil in syria
it's gonna be ours we're gonna keep the
troops there protecting our oil which
we're gonna get money from well these
companies sell weapons i mean they're
big companies they don't sell the grade
of weapon they sell
outside of the united states military is
lower grade this is why trump was one of
the best presidents i've ever had at
least in the modern era because when he
couldn't get the troops out of syria
because he wanted a complete withdrawal
and they were like no we have to keep
some men he goes out publicly and says
you know i wanted to get the troops out
of syria but we got to keep it about 200
so we can take the oil and i was just
like
keep talking keep talking let everybody
hear what you're saying i think trump
knew what he was doing when he was
saying that stuff i think trump likes
the idea of you know america being great
in a strong military but trumps america
first trump wanted oil produced here he
made he helped make and he helped
maintain american energy independence
and then joe biden drops the fumbles the
ball gives the nord stream 2 to russia
and now is begging opec to give us oil
because we're in trouble then he
releases strategic oil that lasts us two
days joe biden
fumble implies an error
i don't believe it was an error i think
he intentionally did this and think of
the jobs the tens of thousands of jobs
that were lost look at our gas prices
what you know i don't know what they are
here it's got to be a lot more than
there was an arm and a leg 350 here
i thought it would be higher this close
to dc yeah so um it's actually way worse
in colorado than it is here which is
really surprising try california oh yeah
i know california but you know we're
looking at all of our energy prices
going up right
they shut down a coal um coal industry
they're shutting down the coal industry
so we're going to look at all the prices
going up thank god we have a great
nuclear power plant in arizona with lots
of i i believe in clean energy but i
also believe in energy that works i want
to know when i turn my air conditioner
on in arizona i'm going to get
the air conditioner is going to work
there's going to be power for it my
bill's not going to you know bring me
under and
keep me from being able to feed my
family so i want energy that is clean of
course but i think nuclear energy is
clean i completely agree and all this
push for wind and solar that's great
fine let's if we want to go that way
that's great but we have to have energy
that is reliable nuclear energy is green
there's no carbon emissions and it has
some of the highest energy output energy
earned on energy invested yet it is for
whatever reason progressives and as much
as i'm a fan even tulsi gabbard opposes
nuclear energy and it's it makes no
sense well a problem with its
reliability is that it's centralized in
plants and that if the power grid goes
down well they have the new mini the new
mini there's a name for it they're fancy
names
the mini the mini nuclear plants they
are are they really and you can pack
them together if you need however
depending on how much power one two
three can do a six pack of them and and
provide
power trust me bill gates was working on
this i i think um if some i'm gonna look
it up earlier now you're creeping me out
and i think that project go back to
throwing some wood on the fire to heat
yeah um i'm gonna look at this speaking
of which i'm from arizona okay
it's freezing in here
you guys are all thank you thank you i'm
wearing a sweater i wear like blankets
and sweaters it's like 70.
cbs news bill gates's mini nukes not a
wacky idea as energy vision as you think
this is cbs news so this is the future
look into it 71 71 degrees
67 i think it's 67. that's not reading
the right temperature it's the 60 61 in
here maybe 67 is where it's set to the
current temperature is 70. i mean my
room is 74 and it's like 10 or 15
degrees warmer than this room well in
arizona and this is probably going to
shock people even from arizona watching
in the summer we keep our air
conditioner at like 80 82. does that
seem really hot yes yeah but when it's
110 outside though
yeah yeah but it's dry relatively true
this is a dry heat you're right
it's fine yeah you don't you don't
notice it as much because it's just like
you're sweating it's evaporating
instantly it gets cold at night though
it does in the winter very cold very
cold like what does it get to at night
in the winter
well in like december january working
down the 30s and 40s at night it really
gets cold at night it's like it's like
i've been to phoenix a few times it's a
huge swing from night and day right very
big i remember dry the dry conditions so
we can heat dry air heats up faster
and it also cools down faster
i remember i was skating uh in phoenix
and it was like 108 and then at night it
was 50. did you is the grand canyon does
it run through arizona yeah we we have
one of the seven wonders of the world in
arizona where the grand canyon state we
drove through there from l.a to ohio and
the heat it got so cold around the
canyon because i think the heat was
falling into the canyon
right yeah well there is no such thing
as cold cold is only when the heat goes
from one to the right so the heat would
be going up it would be colder but i
think literally the heat was falling
into the canyon hot air was falling in
because easy it's hilarious i've been to
arizona year was that when you were
there um like for three years it knows
it was in the summer
it was in june huh of like three years
ago it got down to like 38 at night with
black ice now i i've been to arizona a
lot it's a beautiful state uh especially
sedona so so i just kind of want to ask
i was married in sedona by the way how
are you going to get the hippies to vote
for you in sedona what is your sedona
hippie so donut is changing i was there
for an event um it was a meet and greet
at someone's home we had about i don't
know 75 or 100 people and i said please
don't just bring people who already like
me i want you to bring people in who are
like i don't know and she brought 10
democrats in who are
not happy with the direction the
country's going nine of them ended up
changing their party affiliation after
our meet and greet so people are waking
up to this
nonsense it's happening the leftist
policies don't work the liberal policies
don't work and we can see it we have a
and i don't know how the you know
situation is here regionally but we've
got a state called california some call
it california right next to us and this
is the state that we escaped to uh in
those
june days where it's 120 degrees and we
want to go to the beach people aren't
even doing that anymore california is so
wrecked
from decades of liberal policy so people
are seeing it in arizona and sedona's
changed quite a bit because californians
have been moving over
you know you've heard the don't
california my arizona don't california
or arizona
the situation's gotten so bad in
california that people are just fleeing
they're picking up and they're buying
homes in arizona and it's changing the
landscape of arizona and arizonans don't
like it so they're waking up in places
like sedona there are still some hippie
enclaves there's nothing wrong with
hippies i like hippies
luke's are happy he is a hippie sedona's
changing and people are just wanting a
little more common sense they don't want
to see this influx of uh california
ideas and policies coming in you got to
vote for the candidate who says
camifornia right yeah exactly i mean
have you been there lately
it's pretty bad it is we used to want to
go to the beach you know let's take a
weekend and i don't even want to do it
anymore i'll just swim in the pool it's
happening in west virginia a bit too
because in dc it's really bad so what
happens is the more the wealthier dc uh
people and they're also the periphery of
maryland virginia they're moving further
west and west virginia is pretty awesome
and so what's happening is these people
are moving to west virginia and then
going there they're going on facebook
and that live in the mountain not too
far from me and they're like i heard
someone shooting their guns and this is
inappropriate there are children calling
everyone's like yeah it was probably
like scaring off a bear or something
yeah so if you're if you're worried
about being here just want to let you
know people shoot guns all the time one
of the things that we're hearing is like
there will be like a shooting range and
then all of these urban liberals move
around it knowing this and signing an
agreement saying you realize there's a
shooting range but then once they have
the dominant majority they all say yeah
well now we're going to vote to take it
away yeah yep or they get into the city
council the town council and change yeah
and so uh in west virginia where i'm at
there are uh communists and i i'm i'm
not using that word as a pejorative i'm
not using it uh uh disparagingly
literal people who are of communist
persuasion
getting elected in local elections and
people don't know because they're not
putting their party affiliation for some
of these positions and they're uh
running on a post in some circumstances
like you mentioned with this guy in
arizona well we just was i think it was
in new york some of some of these
protesters are saying the only option is
going what did you hear that when they
were protesting was it chicago yeah the
the only uh solution is revolution
communist revolution yeah i mean and
this is we in arizona asu that student
holding up the sign death to america
this is what we're churning out in these
schools and
it has an effect you know
they're pretty young right now but when
they get older and they start so moving
around tim's place taking over i i i
just found this out because of uh josie
the redheaded libertarian and uh it's
apparently that communists aren't people
under the 1964 civil rights act
uh so i fact check me on this one okay i
don't have a computer what she what she
pulled up you fact checked it i don't
know i trust her she's very
knowledgeable yeah yeah yeah so in the
1964 civil rights act talks about what
you can or can't do you can't
discriminate for this and that reasons
but apparently there's a provision that
says this will not be construed to
provide protections to members of
communist organizations or affiliated
groups under like the american sedition
clause or something like this i bring
that up not because i i think communists
are entitled to their free speech and
activism but i do wonder if there is a
line for sedition you know we we we used
to take it very very very seriously that
if there were people that were going out
outright saying we will destroy this
country they'd be like okay well now
that you said that whatever you do we're
gonna be watching out to make sure
you're not committing sedition that is
you know seeking to subvert or destroy
the united states a lot of people
incorrectly say treason no treason is
providing aid or abetting foreign
adversaries
i wonder
how do we survive as a country because
we believe in free speech even for
people who hate this country but when
you have a massive population not the
biggest they're kind of fringe but
they're still around eight to ten
percent of people who believe this
country is evil and racist
and literally are saying on tv they want
to destroy it
if we just sit back and say okay then
they will
well they're being taught marxism in
schools we're seeing it in universities
it's not being called that they don't
say we're sitting you down class and
we're teaching marxism today they're
teaching them the tenets of that
practice and then they they start to
take on that belief system that ideology
and they are churned out into our world
well the lifestyle
it's
dangerous and it will kill this country
so so what do we do i mean well we have
to start in the schools we have to stop
this curriculum this is why it gets
right down to the most important
vote that you place is for your school
board and we've got to get more parents
involved like i said this one creep that
was on the school board he still is
we're trying to recall him right now
he got on because nobody else ran
and and i'll take a little bit of the
blame as a parent i'm sure a lot of them
are who are looking at this situation
now going why didn't i run but we just
weren't aware and now we are so we have
to jump in and it's it's a grind to run
for public office uh yeah absolutely
it's a sacrifice but we have to do it we
don't get this free wonderful country if
we don't all get involved and stay
involved if you would become governor
what would be your first call of action
what would you do when you first get in
there there's so many things and i've
talked about a lot of them i mean
where do you want to start you want to
start on the board you're one thing the
first thing you sit down at the office
the first thing i'm going to do right
now what is that
well there's a lot of things but let's
talk about we can talk about the border
we can talk about schools i i want to
end all
agreements that we've made with china i
want to bring manufacturing back to
arizona we saw what happened during
covid we couldn't even get medicine we
were out of toilet paper for god's sakes
and now we're relying on our think about
this our medicines
to come from china the country that
started this whole thing up
and this is just unbelievable so we've
got to we've got to bring manufacturing
back i would cancel any deal we have
with china with communist party we're
not going to work with the communist
party
these we can't compete with them when
they have slave labor making all the
junk that they send over we don't want
that junk anymore we don't want to live
with the
that with that on our conscience that we
have a bunch of junk we're buying that's
made by people who are making this
against their will i would immediately
if anybody and i've said this many times
if anybody is fined or charged with
breaking a mask mandate or coveted
mandate for standing up for liberty i
would pardon them on day one a mass
pardon of anybody who gets a ticket or
an infraction or loses a an infraction
on their business license for standing
up to this because we have to have
somebody who's looking out for the
people who are showing courage at this
time it's very hard to show courage and
we saw in the last five years
you know people got canceled for saying
something or putting a tweet out that
talked about what their belief was and
they got canceled and they'd lose a job
well we need to get beyond that and
start making courageous moves so we have
to reward people who are courageous
and do the right thing and if that's a
business that's pushing back against
mandates and they get fined we're gonna
we're gonna relieve them of those fines
because they did the actual right thing
have you thought about setting up a
state cryptocurrency if the u.s
government were to cut off the state for
uh
ignoring their mandates
interesting i've actually had a lot of
people talk to me about crypto what do
you think i mean how do you how would
that look i'm not an expert on
everything i always say that but i'm
always open to hear ideas whether you're
an expert i wouldn't think of myself as
an expert but i would like to see every
state have its own cryptocurrency maybe
a federal cryptocurrency as well that we
could inter trade
well i believe the constitution talks uh
specifically about currency and who can
set it up yeah no nobody other than
congress is supposed to do that yet they
set up the federal reserve to do it
basically ignoring their constitutional
duty it's infuriating at this point if
they reigns are in your hand as a state
as a state governor um
i think you would use it to trade only
within the state at first
because the government us government
federal government wouldn't legitimize
it and they try and stop it and that so
that might cause more problems but if
they're going to cut off financial
services to the state then what other
well i mean that's a scary prospect if
we get to the point where you know we
already have
desantis saying we need a civilian uh
military to be brought back because
well he didn't say this but it's obvious
it's not working between you know joe
biden and and florida joe biden's agenda
is clearly cutting off red states who
are not falling in line with the coast
we have to have governors like desantis
and like what the governor i'll be where
we stand back and we say you're not
going to fly people in here overnight
we're going to fly them to your state
you saw what's happening with joe biden
taking the kids in the middle of the
night and flying over tennessee i mean
that is evil he's smuggling children
trafficking yeah my it's crazy it's
unbelievable and and i love that
governor descent he does a lot of things
that i've actually talked about when
we're doing rallies and such he'll like
we're talking about vote for me and i'll
just do what desantis does no well and i
talked about that i said we need people
who are who are strong and going to do
the right thing a good leader knows
right from wrong and does the right
thing no matter what kind of pressure
they're under and our current governor
didn't do that
he was a republic he is a republican
but when it came time to shut our state
down
he folded when the leftist mayors of
tucson and phoenix and flagstaff were
pressuring him to shut the state down
and mask our children and he folded
every single time to the activists in
the media
you're sitting there watching going come
on do the right thing governor ducey do
the right thing and uh it was so
disappointing he shut our state down
twice so we need strong people that
don't just wait to see what's governor
desantis gonna do okay people like that
then i'll do it we need people who are
gonna do the right thing first governor
desantis might even copy me and i love
governor desantis so desantis can run
for re-election saying i'm going to do
what kerry lake's been doing no i mean
he's a rock star don't get me wrong we
need more people like that people who've
got a backbone i'm told not to say balls
so i'm going to say back
people with a backbone and you know and
the problem is we get so many
uh people who run and it's hard to run
unless you have a machine behind you i'm
fortunate i've got
almost 30 years in arizona people know
who i am they've invited me into their
home they trust me i understand the
state i've covered the issues for nearly
three decades
and i'm run i've got huge name id you
can't put a price on that i've got 85
percent name id in the state of arizona
i'm running and being funded by the
people of arizona not the swamp but if
any other person wants to run they have
to find a funding source that's what i
feel like political parties are yeah
like if you ever think about just
shirking political parties completely
and
once you're even after you're in awe
well i mean i think being a trump
republican like you know when trump
started out it was almost jerking he was
like a libertarian liberal guy that went
in and just like what party should i
pick this one looks easier so i'll go
that direction well but no he's he's a
conservative i mean i think trump is a
conservative for sure i'd be interesting
at the time
people were conservatives like him
because they're like he's a new york
liberal you know so he's not far left or
anything the establishment didn't like
him because they were like oh crap he
might win but i'll tell you what was
really interesting i think it was vox
who wrote that the democrats had gone
nuts because trump had stolen some of
their core policy positions like working
with unions and the working-class stuff
and it's just populism it's just america
first yeah and we're gonna help the
workers of america
but democrats were like okay now what do
we do well the democrats sold out the
worker oh yeah right with nafta they
sold out the worker under bill clinton
we started to deal with uh with china
the political elite and when i say that
that's democrat and republican sold out
this country and the working man and
woman even before that with kissinger
literally sending over all the jobs over
the chin to china getting rid of uh
domestic men's places like united states
upstate new york where it's just it's
like a graveyard of old factories
rusting and falling apart in michigan
this is what happens when you're not
america first you want to know what what
i've i'm just uh man this is a
gives me hope white pill we say
i think i i don't like having
politicians on the show very often you
know uh i i've talked to lydia about
booking politicians it's challenging
because politicians they give you
politician answers and i think you've
been absolutely forthcoming i'm not a
politician and that's the thing there's
a lot of people and they're like well
you know i got to be careful and i'm
just like here we go i was like tell us
what you want to do tell us what you
think but regardless of that i will say
to the people we've had on who have been
running it's still it's been infinitely
better than the traditional tv run
fake personality this is this is why
things are changing because
you came on the show we had never talked
before this lydia books you you show up
we meet for the first time i drive
through the woods and i'm thinking this
is going to be the end of me
but but uh what happens is we come
upstairs we sit down we turn the camera
on the camera's on live and we just talk
yeah that's great so no script it's so
funny because my opponents will say oh
she won't talk and i'm like are you
kidding you need to follow me around i
answer i always say they go what can
what do you want to talk about i could
ask me anything yeah i have to ask you
this because a lot of people i'm sorry
tim are commenting in your chat room
about about weed
where do you stand on personal use of of
drugs for individuals and the larger
concept of victimless crimes what's your
stance on those issues oh okay um well i
we we do have recreational pot use in
arizona and that's been settled
um i i think we need to follow the law
though i don't want it getting in in the
hands of my children i don't think it's
good for their developing mind so we
need to really be strict with the laws
on that
i'm not going to go in and with the you
know and just start revoking laws that
the people have passed but you do have
recreational use for in arizona 18 and
older is it is it 18 and older yeah
i know i think it's 21. alcohol
yeah i think i think it's 21. i should
know that but i do i don't know luke you
you thought you had a gotcha but it was
an easy one it wasn't a gotcha it's your
comment section literally
ask her about
marijuana you know if you want to do
that if that's what you're into great if
you if you want to
smoke cigarettes and that's what you're
into in your legal age as long as you're
following the law i want to make sure we
do follow the law
because i do think it's really bad for
our develop young people's developing
minds if they're using that they're
going to school it's already difficult
enough i agree you know
because if you have a law that's a
really bad law that's like the nazis
made laws that made it illegal to be
jewish basically as a governor as
someone in control and supposed to be
like my job is to uphold the law what do
you do when you come across a bad law
like that well i think what you do as a
governor is you come in and you start
working with the legislature and you say
here are my priorities
we need to make sure we're protecting
families we're helping businesses grow
and i'm talking arizona businesses we've
really neglected arizona businesses the
small businesses medium-sized businesses
really suffered under our two shutdowns
in arizona now everyone's asking about
dmt sorry
what is that dimethyltryptamine it's a
chemical that you're is produced in your
brain and animals and plants that causes
you to do them
everyone has to break from the trip when
you smoke it the thing is that we have
so many serious issues right now we've
got our schools teaching marxism to our
kids teaching anti-american history we
have a border that's wide open fentanyl
coming from china
china sending their fentanyl to mexico
for the cartels to run across our border
is coming in we've got uh defund the
police effort going on in our state our
crime is through the roof up hundreds of
percent thousand percent
murder rates violent crime i mean i
could go on and on the list goes on
we've got water water crisis in arizona
that we have to confront we have a ton
of issues so i mean we can go into all
these smaller things
[Music]
yeah i'm just trying to get a little the
priorities are uh well you know dmt it's
illegal it's a federally illegal
considered illegal drug but it's you
know relatively easy to synthesize the
body
so that's whether or not it should be
illegal i guess maybe so let me turn it
back on you
what do you think about california and
oregon where you just openly can shoot
up drugs
we stopped going to san francisco we
used to go to san francisco in the
summer you know again we stopped going
to california pretty much um
and we were there with our little ones
our kids were little and we literally
walked by two people shooting up drugs
and it was so horrifying covering the
kids eyes and and that was kind of the
beginning of the real fall of of san
francisco i think all drugs should be
legal recreationally all drugs however
hard drugs have to be done in like
facilities it would be it would be
regulated to a certain degree and i'll
speak lightly on this to a certain
degree i like what portugal has done in
terms of reducing a lot of the addiction
i think we need to treat a drug abuse
like a disease
i'm not saying it is a disease but i
think we need to treat it as like
something that needs to be solved for
people and not putting people in prison
because of it so i i think the way we've
handled victimless crimes over drug use
has been absolutely wrong and you get
someone who gets it i'll use the opioid
crisis because a really good example
that hits home for a lot of people who
lost their jobs you get their factories
shipped overseas you get these people
who are struggling to make ends meet
some of them get hurt some of them get
prescribed opioids some of them fall
into it because they're desperate and
and depressed and now they're they're
they're going to be locked up in prison
because of it no no this is a failing of
the establishment political
political class gutting our system
allowing big allowing drugs to pour in
from china and through big pharma and so
i look at it like here's what i think we
should not be imprisoning people for
this you catch someone on the street the
police should be like you're coming with
us sir to this facility where we're
gonna get you clean we're gonna help you
out you you can do it but it has to be
done under the strict guidelines so
you're not in the middle of the street
you give it to kids felony any of that i
need that distribution of kid stuff i
don't stand for but i don't like the
idea of victimless victimless crimes i
don't know i don't i don't there's a lot
of times there's a lot of despair right
now and you talked about even um
with social media and what you're seeing
you think you're you're you're calling
up what you want to see but the tech
tyrants are really pushing a lot of
despair our way as well there's despair
in in the culture that is around us
there's despair in the way our kids are
being taught when you're taught that you
know america is a bad place and and just
all of the to judge somebody by the
color of their skin with some of the
racist stuff they're pushing with crt
and sel
you know i'm a big believer in the words
of martin luther king jr you judge
someone by the content of their
character but we're pushing just so much
negativity everywhere that our kids are
depressed and then the shutdown on top
of it
you know our shutdown caused by fouchy's
mandates
and you know each county i'm sure your
county had one we had we had a state
health director who who did more to
damage our health in arizona than
improve it these shutdowns caused mental
illness to spike drug overdoses to spike
isolation to spike
depression to spike
people
lost their lives because of these
shutdowns they did not help our health
they hurt our health
and so there's just a lot of
and you see freaking we're going to go
to look at their lives because of the
taste the suicide absolutely it's it's
horrifying when i when i did the prageru
video i talked about i lived in a
neighborhood with a lot of elderly
neighbors they're wonderful and my
neighbor one of my neighbors was the
most beautiful 90 year old woman ever
she swam every day she walked she had
lunch with her friends
and i saw her about six months in to
this whole shutdown and all of it she
was in a walker walking to the mailbox
and i didn't even recognize her i mean i
i stopped the car and i looked at her
and i was like oh my gosh
what has happened
her life you know these later years it's
so important for our older people to
stay active and you know it's just
really tragic and that's what i realized
the propaganda being put out is
dangerous and it's killing people and i
will not be a part of that
we're gonna go to super chats take some
audience questions so i will say thank
you all so uh for your super chat smash
the like button subscribe to the channel
become a member at timcast.com i'm gonna
try and go through this and find
questions directly for carrie usually
we'll just read a bunch of stuff but uh
for everybody there's a question for you
you know can i say one thing yeah my
husband could say looking at me
kerrylake.com
k-a-r-i-l-a-k-e dot com you can see
where i stand on you can see my platform
not everything is covered there people
will say what about
dmt is that what it was
there i do not have a platform uh item
on dmt
so i'll i'll address that real quick um
just
it's a fascinating drug they're they're
doing a lot of research on it and people
say that you know they have very
profound experiences
unique to any other drug but more more
importantly is a lot of the stories
about it are that people who take it in
the same space
experience the same thing and it makes
them feel like there's something bigger
there that's why it always comes up dmtr
you take it every night do you know that
you take it every night
when you dream yeah
it's a natural chemical you know i'm a
big big believer in prayer and i think
that there's a lot of we've taken god
out of our entire society and that
started really in the 60s and and
everyone's everyone's got an emptiness
inside of them that
your faith and god can fill but we've
taken that out of our society and
everyone has that emptiness and they're
going to fill it with something so you
need to find something and i i'm a big
believer in prayer and the bible
and i'm not trying to push that if you
want that that's fine but i'm i'm not
going to experiment with dmt
i'm fine with prayer and i think that
there's a lot of power in that i've
thinking and kind of meditating and i
guess praying is one way of thinking
i'll think like um i'll figure out the
answer i'll think that for instance and
that'll give me a very different
response than what is the answer like if
i'm talking to something
and it seems to respond more than just
telling myself i'm going to figure it
out like there's a reciprocation yeah
we're going to a friend of mine said to
me i was waking up a lot in the middle
of the night like three o'clock and
um she said oh that's just god telling
you you haven't had time to prayer god
knows you're alone and that's when my
life has been very busy lately and so
now instead of when i wake up at three
in the morning i don't say oh my gosh
i'm sleepless i go oh this is a really
great opportunity to talk to god yeah
and it's so important and i wish more of
our kids had access to
faith
um you know and we've got a lot of
atheists out there and these their
children have never been raised to even
know about the bible
uh i think it's it's worth
teaching our kids about i'll tell you
this i'm uh i'm not an atheist i believe
in god but i am not theistic i i grew up
catholic briefly i do not believe in the
bible but i certainly value a lot of
what's in it because i've had a lot of
great philosophical discussions in that
regard and i think uh
a a wise person a smart person is going
to try and read as much as they can to
understand as much as they can i'll tell
you we gotta go to super chats
absolutely i'm fired up i love talking
to you all right so we have a ton of
super chats just saying they're from
arizona and they're big fans and i'm
trying to make sure i pull up the ones
that are questions for you okay and i
kind of feel i kind of feel funny
because i've seen so many like uh
political interviews where the questions
are always the the lamest questions so
guys feel free like luke asked about dmt
super chat us whatever question
are you saying that was a lame question
or a good question that's a good
question yeah because you stumped me i
was like i don't know obama is this a
machete by the way insidious yes yes it
is
i'm listening to like an interview with
obama and he's like we're going to take
real questions online and i'm like oh
they're going to ask about the kids he
bombed and they're like i'm wondering
about paying for tuition so here's are
you the greatest or the great president
tell me anything but these are this this
one's so ugly it's just a very general
basic question from riker ruiz he says
carrie i'm an arizona native and i feel
like i'm being priced out of my own
state what will you do about this as a
governor we need to build more homes i
mean we
got to build more homes right now and we
need to make it easier on the home
builders right now i talk to people who
are developers and they say 25 of the
price of a home is is taxing and
excessive uh permits and things like
that there's a lot of regulation that
goes into the pricing on a home but
we're also seeing californians come over
they come over and let's say um you know
ian's selling his house for 250 000.
and you come over from california and
you go i've got a ton of cash i'm just
going to offer you
uh 275.
arizonans can't do that they're they're
trying to so all the californians are
buying it the house prices keep going up
up up
and we really need to build a wall
between arizona and california i'm just
joking
but we have the californians coming in
and they're bringing the prices up and
so we need to we really do need to uh i
wish californians would stay and try to
fix their state so that arizona can
have uh prices uh for homes that are
reasonable how are you looking at 3d
printing
3d printing housing technology is pretty
cool yeah it is cool but i want to try
and read as many questions as i can
so we've got william martin he says
hello carrie lake this may be a long
shot but are you aware of a youtuber
named razorfest he is very tuned in
arizona politics and i believe he has
been a support supportive of your
campaign in the past i have not heard of
him him or her i don't know razorfest
yeah he's a dude um i felt like that was
a great question
it's an easy answer no i'm sorry i
haven't we thank him for his support you
see this stuff he's he he has great work
and i think it's just and he lives in
arizona
he does he's interested
he did not like john mccain i recall
a lot of people a lot of people did
there you should uh maybe you guys can
uh a lot of people yeah a lot of a lot
of support here let me see
uh
gotta try and find a good good direct
question just being so nice everyone a
lot of people are saying their big fans
are from arizona so you can read those
you just you're just you're just glazing
right over the
it's getting quiet though
he's like tim's like we've got to get to
these questions we got to get to him now
we're fine we're all sitting here
looking at tim going that's right well
it's good
i'll have like two right there but but a
lot of them are just very much big
support for you yeah so i want to make
sure you know we get an opportunity to
actually have questions that people
might not normally get because this is
that opportunity i'm telling you guys
this is your opportunity to ask
literally anything you know i mean if
you ask something that's completely
untoward obviously figuratively yeah uh
art mandalay ah art good to hear from
you vandaly industries that's right
that's right you get the reference right
yeah uh great to see uh carry on irl
just studied a hundred dollars to our
campaign thank you carrierlink.com
carrie no more crt no more woken sanity
the az universities don't fulfill their
charter this needs to be fixed asap and
you're the only one who will do it i
will i've been calling out asu and i've
been calling out michael crowe the
president
i don't think any i know of any
politician who's called him out by name
very powerful guy but we're supposed to
have an affordable education at asu and
the price keeps going up up up up up
and it's become a woke institution we
don't want that in arizona and
we should be holding back some of the
state funds some are all of them if
they're going to continue along if
they're teaching kids to hate this
country
that they're putting up signs death to
america something's wrong at asu and
they're throwing a fit because
uh a student by the name of rittenhouse
dared to apply or to attend online
this is wrong and we need michael crowe
to stand up as the president of asu
and say this is nonsense we're going to
stop it and the governor should be
calling him and saying what the hell is
going on over there this is ridiculous
between you and him between michael crow
and me that would be into well and the
debates are going to be fine i can't
wait i still sometimes look back at
trump's debates
and i think that was some of the best
debating i've ever seen absolutely and
people want to go oh he you know he
didn't it wasn't a good debater i'm like
are you kidding me
that was the best debating it was wwe it
was
all right here's one that can get us in
trouble but i'm going to read it anyway
because i'm not going to shy away from
these questions so keep in mind nicholas
delay says hi carrie buckeye resident
here miss you on the news the razer
force has your back have you talked to
tim about the 2018 mail-ins for kristin
cinema
no do you know about that
do you know what's he referring to the
the 2018 mail ends i'm assuming that
means ballots or something yeah i mean
does he want to uh expound on that just
no no that's that's the question i i
don't know if you know
we had election problems in 2018 that
were never looked into um
you know there were there were issues i
remember with the chain of command there
were issues with chain of command
and adrian fontes was in charge in 2018
he's still in charge he's now running
for secretary of state which is even
scarier he was in charge of maricopa
county elections now he's running for
secretary of state these are people we
don't want running our elections
they can't even admit that there were
major problems so i don't know how deep
we want to get into the elections but we
as arizonans need to really look at the
people running our elections because
we've had some
shady characters or get a governor who's
gonna
you know well i mean when i'm governor
we're gonna go through that forensic
audit and we're gonna fix everything and
if people defrauded the voters and i
don't want to get into too much detail
because i know youtube has some issues
with us talking about that because
there's censorship unfortunately in this
country and it's going to become
outlawed in arizona we're not going to
allow censorship
but um anybody who defrauded the voters
is going to be investigated and they
should be locked up right now frankly
they should be locked up right now and
i'm not the governor right now and i'm
not the attorney general but
these people need to go in there and do
their damn job
all right we got frank reynolds he says
rand paul for president 2024 would you
support
well if president trump runs in 2024 i'm
going to i'm going to support president
trump
if president trump says you know what
i've had it with this i'm gonna just
enjoy i mean he's got a great life i'm
gonna get golf or whatever
then i would look at rand paul i think
he's he's a great american patriot he
cares about this country
he's to me he's one of the greats there
i mean didn't he just say today that
fouchy should be locked up did he say
that yeah for five years for lying uh to
congress i'm thinking why just five
years huh
here's a good one um first let me ask
you how long you were if you were in
phoenix for 20 30 years i moved there in
94 drove into town on a hot august day
falconizer says carrie did you see the
phoenix lights
i was working that night as a matter of
fact all of the phoenix lights
documentary documentaries that were
produced in movies
show usually they show me anchoring that
night
we were on the air that night and we're
like oh my you know the phones were
lighting up their phoenix lights so
there's a bunch of different you know
over the years they've done a lot of the
documentaries on it is this where
there's like all those blinking lights
and it looked like a battleship in the
sky or something
that i can't believe how big that story
was what was it a bunch of air like hot
air balloons lined up i forget they say
it was weather balloons do you remember
flares i mean there's a bunch of
different
or a v-shaped alien are you looking at a
video of it right now like a newspaper
of it article of it or something there's
like a weird v-shaped light things
interesting
that got a lot of air time we talked
about phoenix lights well we've forever
decades right there's a lot of
government i would imagine like space
program work done in the desert
underground and stuff in the mountains
basis are you near area 51 is that in
there
okay i don't i don't know what this
means but i'm going to read it anyway
uh-oh phillip
summit says born and bred too sunny in
here you have my vote carrie
all you have to do is disavow the sun
devils and bear down
is that all it takes for me to gain
tucson but lose phoenix okay i'll tell
you what i don't like the woke-ism over
at
the sun devil asu sun devils but i know
a lot of the sun devils don't like it
either
nobody wants that and
we've got great institutions of learning
higher education they got to do better
they got to do better david sharpening
says mrs lake will you appoint michael
mallis your press secretary
do you know michael i don't he's uh uh
so um dave smith
if he does run for the libertarian party
president presidential uh to be a
candidate or to run for office michael
malus who is one of the the most
notorious internet trolls
uh he's gonna be his press secretary and
we're big fans of michael he's a good
friend of the show what makes what makes
him so uh you know unique he's very
smart he's an anarchist he's a writer
he's a writer he wrote he's written
about north korea
um
and he's very anti-establishment and uh
he's critical of the of the media and
the propaganda and the lies and he's
just got he's got sharp wit good memory
so if there's anybody who could take
them into arizona no no texas texas
we'll probably they're maybe hire
someone in arizona
you know speaking of north korea and the
universities though remember the um
student
park
yeah who left nor she she
was a defector from north korea said
that she experienced more brainwashing
going to an ivy league college princeton
i believe it was than she experienced in
her time in north korea this is how
effed up
our universities are we gotta they're
being brainwashed worse than what's
going on in north korea think about that
for a minute we have to address the
curriculum in this country here's the
poisoning of our children's minds uh
here's a good one for you raymond g
stanley jr says carrie how does the
american first movement handle foreign
affairs are we still the world police
against evil what about women being
drafted
well i i talk about china all the time i
mean the ccp is not our friend and we
need to bring manufacturing back and i
think we have an opportunity to do that
much like president trump's opportunity
zones and didn't get enough coverage in
the media because the media didn't want
to showcase anything that the president
did well we need to bring back we're
calling it resiliency zones and we want
to do that in arizona where we can you
know manufacture some of the essentials
that we need so we don't have to rely on
these countries like
china
um what was the other question um women
being drafted women being drafted yes so
that's i'm not i'm not for uh i don't
think we need the draft we've got a
volunteer military right now
if women want to fight i think it should
be optional um i i am
very much about making sure women have
the opportunity to do the things that
that really are meaningful in life
though and i think motherhood is really
meaningful
one of one of the questions was about
like foreign policy and it said world
police i think they're specifically
referencing war
uh
are there i'm gonna i'm i'm applying for
the job of arizona governor
i don't think we're going to be starting
a war in arizona i hope not sending well
what if the uh what if the feds call in
the national guard for deployment say in
a foreign country or whatever
and and what are you asking i mean uh
what's your i guess i don't know exactly
what you could do if the feds were like
we're going to pull national guard and
send them to iraq or something but i
just i'm curious your thoughts on
something like that happening how you
view it positive negative
i not maybe i'm not for starting a bunch
of wars i mean i really loved president
that one of the reasons i really loved
president trump was that he was trying
to end the endless wars
um i'm i'm about running for arizona
governor protecting arizona putting
arizona first and bringing making sure
that we are a great climate we want to
preserve our western heritage we're
having so many people move in and
arizona is if y'all have you all been
there at least once oh yeah a bunch of
rooms it's such a welcoming state that i
was able to in 94 drive into town and
feel like within a few weeks i'm like
i'm an arizonan you can't do that in new
york you can go move to new york you can
live there five years and you still
can't say i'm a new yorker they just
won't let you say it so it's a welcoming
state but we are we don't want to be a
doormat and we've let so many people in
that it's changing that feel of arizona
we want to be uniquely western and uh
uniquely arizona they have a really good
country fried steak in arizona and
phoenix that i love i literally fly in
there just to get the fried steak i'm
gonna look up the name it's a it's an
old uh traditional place uh western
place they have license plates and a
bunch of pretty stuff all over the world
what it's called what is it called i
love that place what is it
what
texas yes that's it i love it that's my
favorite this is a great place i've been
there like 50 times we got we got a good
question from chrissy she says what's
your plan for the water crisis to solve
it you know what we're actually looking
at um i'm open to all ideas but we have
to deal with our water crisis because we
have a growing population people are
moving to arizona and it's a wonderful
state people want to move there but we
can't survive if we don't address our
water issues long term and so we can
obviously look at things like runoff and
making sure that we're doing the right
things
on a smaller level but i want to work
with
our partners to the south mexico and
work on a desalination plant and we can
provide the power through these micro
nuclear
plants as we were talking about and work
with mexico northern mexico needs water
the whole region needs water and i want
to help spearhead that bring other
western states into it but desalination
works that's how israel gets their water
an israel israeli company started a
desalination plant in southern
california it is expensive but if we
invest in this the price will come down
and we we can't afford to say oh we're
not going to deal with our water issue
because it's expensive
think about when the when the taps go
dry we're really most valuable
yes absolutely you're thinking
desalination in california desalination
in mexico because it frankly it's so
difficult through the regulations and
the bs you have to go through to deal
with california it's easier to work with
mexico and make that happen there are
there are challenges however so we've
we've talked about it i've done actually
a few mini docs on desalination is that
the runoff is basically brine and it is
heavier than the water so when it when
they're expelling
it just kills the lower level life forms
on the in the ocean on the sea floor
which causes an upward chain of events
where you end up with mass die-offs
i'm not saying desalination
have you seen the study that says that's
not true there is one i'm going to send
it to you okay you have seen it i
haven't i haven't where i i actually
read one study because obviously we have
to look at the environmental issues and
concerns that we could have but i read
one study where it actually increases
sea life and i'm going to send it to you
i don't i wish i had my computer in
front of me right now i i i don't think
that that is necessarily an outright
disqualifier for desalination
desalination anyway but i am still
curious i feel like there's still going
to be an upper threshold of how much
water we can be extracting and using but
you know for now i do like the idea i've
been to the plants i've seen them
they're really fascinating have you been
the one in california or israel oh yeah
that's i was just looking at a video on
that cool right no i haven't been there
i want to go there it's like a whole
bunch it's it's crazy water is forced at
high pressure through all of these like
hundreds of tubes it is ridiculous the
filtration they have it's cool and then
you actually can watch the brine get
ejected and then we talked to an
environmental group who said their
concern is you know the ryan run off but
right let's get some more of these uh
questions whatever we do though we have
to look at that and and i think we can
come up with the solutions if the
solution is the brine we can come up
with a solution for that we have to have
water here's a spicy one for you okay
shiloh jorgensen says what's your stance
on abortion weak cut off and what not
i am pro-life and i am 100 pro-life
i
if you can if you can convince me that
killing
a baby is okay then then maybe i'll
change my mind
but
there's a child we've we have it's so
radical that we have
convinced our young people for a couple
generations now that it's okay to take
the life of their unborn in the womb
we've got mothers taking the life of the
baby in their womb and we've convinced
them that that's health care that's not
health care what about medical issues
if there's a medical issue with the baby
or the mother do you think there should
be exceptions in that regard well if the
mother's life is at risk yeah i mean we
don't want to lose moms
but that's not really what i think i
think those are that's a real rare when
that's happening this is this is the
challenge i have and i say you know for
um
anti-establishment anti-state reasons i
find myself pro-choice because i don't
like the idea of
i don't i don't know how you actually
would
implement would there be a government
arbiter or there'd be some kind of like
government regulation for when it comes
to a woman getting approval for an
abortion for a medical reason you know
what i mean
well we're trying to bring it back to
the states the states you know we had
the judiciary decide and the people have
been taken out of that equation
i think that's wrong obviously you know
brett kavanaugh said how is this a court
decision it's the legislature he needs
to deal with it i'm like he's right you
got to get back to that the constitution
i mean it was set up and it was pretty
much perfect
yeah so i'm pro-life i'm
unapologetically pro-life um when you
hold a baby in your arm i don't know if
any of you have kids here no no i don't
yeah
somebody's just saying
millennials
come on tim what's going on here
got a girlfriend now right yeah and you
know i i think i just work 16 hour days
and that's probably the problem
okay
don't miss out on that don't miss out on
that you'll regret that
yeah
definitely that's what everybody says in
their death it's the most amazing thing
my regret is i only had two kids i kind
of fell into the hole like out of work
and i know i wish i would have had more
kids coming from a family of nine
and you know there are
there are options people go what if you
can't afford the baby you know there's
help out there there truly is and if you
really don't if you really say i'm
pregnant i don't want this baby
every state has a safe haven law now
if you're pregnant and you say i don't
want this child
you can no questions asked give that
baby away
but it's not the baby's fault it's not
the baby's fault and we need to really
uh i think if we're a country
that finds it okay to take uh to kill a
baby in the mother's womb we got some
real problems here's a here's a good one
simple oscar
miranda says how will you secure the
border with no support from the federal
government
uh well we've got the materials down
there let's go down there and start
securing it start building the damn
fence i mean really build a wall
yeah
no arizona arizona is a complex state
and people don't understand this um
we we have i think only 20 miles of
president trump's wall to complete i'm
hearing that wait wait 20 miles and it's
done for arizona yes but we also have we
also have an indian reservation in
odam reservation so that's sovereign
land we can't just go on there until
we're building a wall on your nation so
we have some complexities
but
we've got i was down at the border and
within five minutes of arriving and
stepping out of the vehicle people were
walking over
under joe biden's policy
we had that president trump's policy
remain in mexico policy was the best
border policy i've ever seen in my 27
years covering arizona it worked
and joe biden came in on day one and
pulled that
and now we're seeing a crisis we need to
build the wall first of all we need to
sue the federal government for failing
to protect us and while that lawsuit is
working its way through the system let's
go down and start building the wall we
have
many uh
many miles of arizona state land we
could be building it on and let's let's
finish these little gaps they're coming
through a funnel where there's a gap in
the president's wall and it is on
federal land but let's build the wall
anyway what's joe biden going to do
arrest a sitting governor
i mean honestly
but we have to have do you think he
would
um i would well we're not that far away
i would welcome that challenge because
he's failing at his duty the the federal
government is failing us in arizona they
are to protect us
and they're not doing it he's failing
across the board in the entire world
absolutely yeah but considering you're
running for arizona i think you know
that's your yeah so i think we start
building the wall we start building the
wall and when i said fence you caught
that but if we can't afford it people
say wait a minute there's no money for
it well there's a couple ways we could
do it if they say we can't afford it an
israeli fence okay president trump's
wall costs 20 million a mile i believe
that was the figure an israeli type
fence is one million a mile
so we just need to get a barrier up a
very strong barrier to keep people from
coming in they're coming in from where
there's a gap in the in the wall it's
the stupidest thing to me when i was
reading all these arguments they were
like the wall's pointless because most
of them fly most you know immigrants fly
here anyway and then just stay here and
i'm like that's not trump's argument
trump's argument was like smuggling in
drugs and like and they were like yeah
well you can climb over it i'm like sure
but most can't like i don't know what
you're saying like they kept saying the
walls don't work and i'm like quite
literally they do they in greece they
built a wall and i think i think in
greece they put up a three meter chain
link fence that was it right and then
all of a sudden illegal immigration
dropped by like 90 well and while we're
building it we can put up whatever
barrier we can if we have to do bar
whatever we can we've got to get these
areas that they're coming through uh
blocked
but we also need we know we have an
issue not an issue we have a sovereign
nation sitting on our border that spans
arizona and mexico most people don't
realize that we can't just go onto a
sovereign nation and build a wall so we
need to make sure that our law
enforcement along the counties that are
surrounding this area where the drugs
and people are coming in have the money
i'm talking to sheriffs who say we don't
have
money in our in our budget for overtime
we need overtime right now because we've
got so much coming across the border so
we need to take this 1.6 billion dollars
the feds have given us for coveted
relief
sent a bunch of it down to our sheriffs
along the border to pay overtime and i
think we should enable them to deputize
arizonans who are willing and able to
help secure the border
we've got a lot of veterans a lot of
former law enforcement a lot of
patriotic arizonans who want to help
and
create you know a posse and help out all
right we'll just try and do a couple
more lone wolf asks do you have any
plans to combat social media censorship
and narrative propaganda and what can
those of us not in arizona due to
support you without simultaneously
supporting the gop's bank account they
can come right to kerrylake.com and make
a donation i am i am supported and i'm
funded by the people of arizona does
that not this one does that not go
through win red they can send a check if
they want to go that route because i
think i understand what they're saying
yes some people have a real problem with
win red um and you can send a
a check i know that's kind of do people
still write checks i know they do we get
a lot of dust checks yeah we get checks
as well and we appreciate that because
we don't lose any uh percentage to that
can they paypal you directly
is that legal that's a good question can
i ask my people
can they bitcoin
we're going to start that soon bitcoin
can they bitcoin you oh apparently we're
going to start that soon wow
checks are easier to track and that's
why yeah people use well people go i
don't want my name and you know you have
to give your name and you have to give
your occupation this is part of kind of
the rules of its campaign but i think
with winrat it's like
that gives a percentage to the gop as a
whole or something i'm not entirely sure
i know act blue is kind of like that
all right what was the first part of his
question i missed uh plans to combat
social media censorship and narrative
property i want to make censorship i
want to outlaw censorship in arizona
you know we're a second amendment state
and i want to be a first amendment state
it's sad that we have to first amendment
sanctuary pardon me it's sad that we
should have to even have these sanctuary
counties and cities and states
the constitution should just be upheld
everywhere
but we need to start
finding these companies that are
censoring people
if you we have free speech in this
country and until we come and fight back
against these tech tyrants who are
making a gazillion dollars
um we've got to start sent we've got to
start finding them for censoring
americans people go oh this is a private
company this is the town square
can you imagine if in the old days you
guys don't probably don't remember the
old you know wall phone the kitchen
phone oh of course if if they heard tim
talk into luke and they didn't like what
the phone company didn't like what you
two were talking about they just cut
your line yeah that's what we're doing
it would have been a global
outrage 80s if that had happened i
missed the i'm starting to really miss
the kitchen phone by the way
it felt a lot more secure my mom still
got one keep keep talking in the future
about the censorship stuff because
i i feel like
having the government decide what
companies can make their own terms of
service be is a bit fascist so but
allowing them full reign to do whatever
they want seems to be failing so that
we've got to find some other method i'm
looking at freeing the software code of
large social networks
so that other people can spin up a
version of the network like twitter they
can have their own twitter with their
own terms of service that will interlock
with the other twitter so you can still
follow people from either network
if this twitter wants to ban you they
can but you still have your twitter now
we'll just do that with the on
foundation yeah it seems like
but but a lot of people are starting up
social media new platforms it's just a
matter of finding the one that everybody
wants to be on and i don't know why
anybody wants to be on twitter i'm on it
it is a cesspool it's full of bots it's
right
one one last very important one i'm
sorry i couldn't get to every single one
and i was definitely trying not to avoid
the spicier ones but i will just first
by start by saying
where we consider you know having our
business and opening up uh new studios
because we're doing a bunch of new shows
social media censorship protections is
one of the biggest issues so we've
looked at florida when desantis is like
we're gonna look into this i'm like
maybe we set up a headquarters in
florida so that's a good thing but
there's one there's one other thing uh
yeah right if you do that one other
thing though caleb b says and i'll tell
you this this one could be very big for
me moving to arizona or setting up shop
there
will you nullify the nfa and other
federal gun laws pertaining to
suppressors like other states have
proposed what if the feds start
interfering
well i'm all about pushing back against
the feds right now i mean we've got 3000
miles away from arizona the feds are
telling us how to live our life what to
say when we can work what we can buy you
know it's just ridiculous
i am i am not for
adding additional gun laws to arizona so
in texas i think kirk gave him wrong
luke oh i think you're gonna talk about
in the interest state versus interstate
yeah texas i think they said we have our
own suppressors you can buy them the the
national firearms act does not apply to
texas made suppressors for texas
citizens so i think that's basically
that's what he's getting at yeah like
i do like that it's funny that i wonder
if this is the same person who wrote me
recently
i like what i like the idea of that i'd
like to look more into it i don't want
to sit here you know after a couple
hours and go yeah i'm all for that i
like the idea of it it's not being sold
outside of texas it's being sold so why
is the federal government taking i yeah
and there's an argument about oh but
someone could take it here and go there
well that would be committing a crime
the federal government can actually stop
if that's the case my thing is you know
what i want to see i want to see
republicans saying it's not about new
gun laws it's about repealing bad gun
laws too is repealing the nfa um
realistic the right thing to do is it
realistic or is it just kind of like if
it's going to happen it'll happen in
arizona we are we are a
truly purely pro-two-way state
and it is a a state where you can come
and you can protect yourself you can
protect your family you can buy ammo i
mean in california you can't even buy
ammo it's like you've got a worthless
piece of metal
that doesn't do anything so i'll just
just a very simplified final question
you would be in favor i know you're the
governor so you can't just do this it's
up to the legislature but you would be
in favor of repealing gun laws in
arizona absolutely wonderful
again people act the governor does have
a lot of power but you have to work with
the legislature and we've taken the
legislature out that's where we got in
trouble with our election
we have to follow the constitution the
the legislature is there's a process for
laws to happen or laws to be repealed
and i'm i'm wanting to work with our
legislature more than the governor we
have now who never goes down never talks
to the men and women who are working in
the legislature we've got to have a
relationship there so that we're not
wasting a bunch of time they're not
passing a bunch of bills that i don't
want to that i wouldn't even consider
signing so i will i will i believe i
will be the most pro-2a governor i'm all
about arizona maybe in the country and
i'll tell you this too a lot of people
need to understand this young leftists
are pro-2a absolutely it's the
establishment liberal democrat types who
don't want guns but young people are
absolutely on the left and the right
being like this is our right and we
should be able to exercise it so we've
gone a bit over
so i'll just say thank you so much for
coming is there any final thoughts you
wanted to add anything i'd love to
invite you to bring your company to
arizona
give me a good reason win win the race
we'll work on it um i i'm just i'm i'm
running for office because i truly love
the state of arizona i'm so worried
about us turning into a blue state into
a state that's like california
and we have a movement afoot in arizona
we have a lot of excitement we are going
to have
massive numbers of people coming to vote
and they're going to come out because of
our movement they see somebody in me
that they know they trust who loves the
state who's doing this for pure motives
and we don't want career politicians
we're done with them they come in on day
one and they have 20 30 years of
political favors i don't have any
political favors my special interest
group it's massive and it's the people
of arizona my final thought on this
trump was the first
but you know hearing you and and seeing
what you're doing so far you know and
and if when you win we'll we'll see what
things you do that deserve criticism but
bringing about a lot of what trump's
policies were america first the working
class these things and doing it
articulately whereas trump was a bit
bombastic this is the evolution i think
we need because i've said look i know a
lot of people who can't get over trump's
personality but if you take his policies
and you get the right person who's
straightforward honest and direct and
tells the media off but is tactful
that's a landslide victory yeah somebody
said you're like trump a little soft
around the edges i said okay that's
great that's a great compliment and i do
take on the media and i will take on the
media i worked in the media i know their
tricks go to my rumble page rumble kerry
lake k-a-r-i-l-a-k-e
i've gone after cnn
nbc if you want to interview me and
you're with the media i will fight back
i will fight back and we have to start
fighting back all right because they're
it's not just oh they're biased they're
hurting this country
yeah i completely agree that's we start
with indoctrination from k through 12 it
then it's uh the cherry on top when you
get more indoctrination in the
universities and then if you didn't get
indoctrinated enough the media finishes
it up agreed all right everybody that
about does it it's friday night we're
gonna we're all gonna hang out have a
good time thanks so much for watching
make sure you support us over at
timcast.com we usually do the green room
special episodes on fridays so that's
like behind the scenes stuff i don't
know i don't know if we have one today
after the holidays things slow down a
little bit we got to pick up speed but
thanks so much for the support smash the
like button subscribe to the channel
share the show with your friends you can
follow us at tim cast irl everywhere
basically everywhere and you can follow
me tim cast carrie do you want to shout
out social media and your website carrie
lake k-a-r-i-l-a-k-e
dot com is my website go there to see
where i stand on all of the issues it's
all laid out you can
make a donation if you want i'm funded
by the people not the swamp and i'm also
on carrie lake on twitter
i'm at the carrie lake on facebook is
anybody still on facebook narrowly no
barely you can't get any correction in
that place anymore yeah i'm on mv cary
lake apparently somebody has my name and
then um instagram as well so uh to
continue the baby talk just really
quickly i want to have seven children
and you could help me do that by
supporting me on
uncensored dot com gun sensor dot com
seven radowski's running around we could
do this you will never regret that
because you support me i'm here thanks
for having me i think you're also going
to get four dogs
at least in your future
i'm ian crossland you can catch me at
ian crossland.net carrie fantastic thank
you so much it was such a pleasure
really good good to see you uh that's it
see you later
i kind of want to go over to luke's
house some afternoon and see what is
going on are you gonna be part of those
seven babies is that me no okay
where is this going
are you trying to join a hair on this
right now
i just was i just want to see what the
chaos is like to see alice and all her
siblings and all little rudowski's that
sounds terrifying and fun so i am sour
patch ladies on twitter you guys are
welcome to follow me thank you so much
for joining us tonight gary
and that about wraps it up for this week
we'll see you all on monday thanks so
much for hanging out we'll see y'all
next time bye guys
you